Put a spring in your step with SiriusXM. Our episodes deal with SiriusXM and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode contains particularly distressing incidents and violence against minors. It may not be suitable for all listeners. Considering herself a bit of a psychic, Judy Barnes sensed something was wrong. Her teenage son, Alan, had failed to return home on Sunday, June 17, 1979, following a night out with friends.
使用 SiriusXM，让您的步伐充满活力。我们的节目涉及 SiriusXM 以及往往令人痛苦的事件。如果您在任何时候觉得需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。有关机密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您应用程序上或我们网站上的本节目简介。本节目包含特别令人痛苦的事件和针对未成年人的暴力行为。可能不适合所有听众。朱迪·巴恩斯（Judy Barnes）自认有点灵媒天赋，她隐约感到有些不对劲。她的十几岁儿子阿兰（Alan）在 1979 年 6 月 17 日星期日与朋友外出过夜后，未能回家。
If he were running late or was otherwise caught up, Alan would always contact his mother to let her know. This time, Judy hadn't heard a thing. Her mind was plagued with visions of Alan, his shot of length blonde hair, deep brown eyes and handsome face, all covered in blood. The weekends of mid-1979 followed the same routine for friends Alan Barnes and Darko Castellan. Nearly every Saturday, Alan would stay the night at Darko's house as his family lived closer to the Adelaide CBD than he did. Just about to turn 17, Alan spent his weekends partying with Darko and enjoying the Adelaide nightlife. On Sunday afternoons, Alan would head back to his family's house in the suburb of Salisbury. The weekend commencing June 16 was no different.
如果他迟到了或者被什么事情绊住了，阿兰总是会联系他的母亲告知她一声。但这一次，朱迪什么消息也没有听到。她的脑海里不断闪现出阿兰的幻影：他那一头垂顺的金发、深棕色的眼睛和英俊的面庞，全都沾满了血迹。1979年年中，朋友阿兰·巴恩斯（Alan Barnes）和达尔科·卡斯特兰（Darko Castellan）的周末过着同样的日常。几乎每个星期六，阿兰都会在达尔科家过夜，因为他家比阿兰家离阿德莱德中央商务区（CBD）更近。即将年满 17 岁的阿兰，周末都在和达尔科一起派对，享受阿德莱德的夜生活。周日下午，阿兰会回到位于索尔兹伯里（Salisbury）郊区的家中。6 月 16 日开始的那个周末也不例外。
Alan spent Saturday night with Darko and the next morning, the pair headed into the city. By the afternoon, Alan was plotting his journey home. Darko planned to join Alan at his place, but Salisbury was 25km northeast of the CBD, so the pair would need a ride. They stood outside the Pennington Hotel on Grand Junction Road, a major thoroughfare in the northern part of the city, and began hitchhiking. Cars passed, but no one stopped to pick up the young men. Darko suggested that Alan go home alone, thinking he might have better luck flagging down a car as a single passenger. Alan agreed, and the two said their goodbyes before going their separate ways. For him, Hodzik knew Alan Barnes and was in the area at the time the 16-year-old was hitchhiking home.
阿兰和达尔科度过了周六晚上，第二天早上，两人前往市里。到了下午，阿兰开始规划回家的行程。达尔科计划和阿兰一起去他家，但索尔兹伯里在中央商务区东北偏北 25 公里处，所以两人需要搭车。他们站在位于该市北部主要交通干道大交汇路（Grand Junction Road）上的彭宁顿酒店（Pennington Hotel）外面，开始搭便车。汽车驶过，但没有人停下来接这两个年轻人。达尔科建议阿兰独自回家，认为他作为单身乘客可能会更容易招到车。阿兰同意了，两人道别后各走各的路。对于他（For him）来说，霍德齐克（Hodzik）认识阿兰·巴恩斯，并且在这个 16 岁男孩搭便车回家的时候就在附近。
As for him drove along Grand Junction Road, he saw who he thought was Alan running up to a stationary White Holden HQ sedan. One of its passenger doors opened as Alan approached. For him could make out another three or four passengers in the Holden. As he drove away, for him glanced up at his rearview mirror. Alan was gone. As that Sunday came to an end with no sign of her son, Judy Barnes phoned the police to report him missing. Four days later, on June 21, Alan turned 17. It was a bleak day with no reason to celebrate.
当他（For him）沿大交汇路开车时，他看到他认为是阿兰的人正跑向一辆停着的白色霍德曼 HQ 轿车（White Holden HQ sedan）。阿兰走近时，其中一扇乘客车门打开了。他（For him）隐约看到霍顿车里还有其他三四名乘客。当他开车离开时，他（For him）瞥了一眼后视镜。阿兰已经不见了。那个星期日在没有她儿子踪迹的情况下接近尾声时，朱迪·巴恩斯打电话给警察报告他失踪了。四天后的 6 月 21 日，阿兰年满 17 岁。这是一个凄凉的日子，没有任何值得庆祝的理由。
He was still missing. Around an hour drive north-east of Adelaide is the South Para Reservoir, the second largest reservoir in South Australia. The artificial lake is surrounded by an expansive bushland reserve, popular with outdoor enthusiasts. On the morning of Sunday, June 24, 1979, two bushwalkers set out on one of the many trails lining the reserve. They neared the South Para Bridge, which spanned a section of the reservoir. The water underneath was extremely low at the time, exposing the lake's muddy base. Down there, laying in the brown mark, was the body of a young man. It was obvious to police that the victim had either jumped, been pushed, or dumped from the top of the bridge.
他依然下落不明。在阿德莱德东北方向大约一小时车程的地方是南帕拉水库（South Para Reservoir），这是南澳大利亚州第二大水库。这个人工湖被广阔的灌木林保护区所环绕，深受户外运动爱好者的喜爱。1979 年 6 月 24 日星期日清晨，两名徒步旅行者踏上了排列在保护区内的众多小径之一。他们走近南帕拉桥（South Para Bridge），该桥横跨水库的一部分。当时底下的水位极低，露出了湖泊泥泞的底部。就在那里，躺在棕色的污泥中，是一具年轻男子的尸体。警察一眼就能看出，受害者是从桥顶跳下、被推下或被抛下的。
His back was broken and twisted from the impact. As such, the major crime squad were called in to assist in a possible homicide. A search of the surrounding area failed to yield any clues. Shortly after the discovery, Judy Barnes opened her front door to find a police officer on her doorstep. The young man found dead at the South Para Reservoir was her son, Alan. The reservoir was 50 kilometres from where Alan was last seen hitching a ride from a Holden HQ sedan. Grand Junction Road moved west to west, providing a direct route via connecting roads to the reservoir. Alan had suffered tremendous physical injury prior to his death.
他的背部因撞击而断裂扭曲。因此，重大案件调查组被召集来协助调查可能的凶杀案。对周边地区的搜寻没有产生任何线索。发现尸体后不久，朱迪·巴恩斯打开前门，发现门廊上站着一名警察。在南帕拉水库发现的年轻死者正是她的儿子阿兰。水库距离阿兰最后一次被看到搭乘霍顿 HQ 轿车的地方有 50 公里。大交汇路由西向西延伸，通过连接道路提供通往水库的直接路线。阿兰在死前遭受了巨大的身体伤害。
After enduring a severe beating, a tapered blunt object such as a bottle had been forced into his rectum, tearing major blood vessels in the area. Rapid blood loss and shock set in, killing Alan within 30 minutes. Despite this, there was no trace of blood on Alan's skin, as his body had been washed prior to being dumped. He was also wearing different clothes to what he had last been seen in. His family confirmed that the clothes were not his and they had never seen them before. Time of death was calculated to have been within 48 hours of the discovery of Alan's body, meaning he was alive for the duration of the week he was missing. Trichloroethanol was found in his system, a byproduct of the sedative hypnotic drug chlorohydrate used to treat insomnia.
在遭受了残酷的毒打后，一根如瓶子般的锥形钝器被强行塞入他的直肠，撕裂了该区域的主要血管。大量失血和休克随即发生，阿兰在 30 分钟内死亡。尽管如此，阿兰的皮肤上却没有血迹，因为他的尸体在被抛弃前曾被清洗过。他穿着的衣服也与最后一次被人看到时不同。他的家人证实这些衣服不是他的，他们以前从未见过。死亡时间经推算是在发现阿兰尸体前 48 小时内，这意味着他在失踪的这一整周内都还活着。在他的体内发现了三氯乙醇（Trichloroethanol），这是用于治疗失眠的镇静催眠药物水合氯醛（chlorohydrate）的副产品。
Furthermore, his blood alcohol content was 0.19%. It was likely Alan was given a Mickey Finn, an alcoholic drink laced with a psychoactive drug, in this case, chlorohydrate. The combination would have weakened the teenager, limiting his ability to fight off his attacker. Whoever had dumped Alan's body intended it to land in the water under the South Para Bridge and sink into the mud. However, the low water level ensured Alan's body remained visible to passers-by. A reward for information was offered to identify Alan's killer, but failed to generate any leads. Tuesday, August 28, 1979, was a warm and pleasant day. Two men sat out in a dinghy in Mutton Cove, 20km northwest of Adelaide City.
此外，他的血液酒精浓度为 0.19%。阿兰很可能是被灌了“米奇芬”（Mickey Finn，一种掺有精神药物的酒精饮料，本案中为水合氯醛）。这种组合会削弱这名少年的体力，限制他击退袭击者的能力。无论谁抛弃了阿兰的尸体，都打算让它落入南帕拉桥下方的水中并沉入泥地。然而，低水位确保了阿兰的尸体依然能被过往行人看到。悬赏提供线索以识别阿兰的凶手，但未能产生任何线索。1979 年 8 月 28 日星期二是一个温暖宜人的日子。两个男人坐在阿德莱德市西北 20 公里处羊角湾（Mutton Cove）的一艘小艇上。
The Cove is situated near where the Port Adelaide River empties out into the sea. The conditions were calm when the men took to the water, perfect for a spot of casual fishing. As they passed a disused wharf near the Osborne Gasworks, something in the water caught their eye. It was a partially submerged garbage bag snagged on some rocks and bobbing with the tide. They boated closer to get a better look. When they approached, one of the men could make out the heel of a human foot sticking out of the bag. When pathologist Dr. Ross James emptied the bag onto a concrete slab to commence an autopsy, he was struck by the horror it contained.
该海湾位于阿德莱德港河（Port Adelaide River）注入大海的地方附近。两人下水时风平浪静，非常适合休闲钓鱼。当他们路过奥斯本煤气厂（Osborne Gasworks）附近一座废弃的码头时，水中的某个东西引起了他们的注意。那是一个半淹没在水中的垃圾袋，挂在几块岩头上，随着潮水上下起伏。他们划着小船靠近以看个究竟。当他们靠近时，其中一人隐约看到一只人脚的脚跟从袋子里伸出来。当病理学家罗斯·詹姆斯博士（Dr. Ross James）将袋子里的东西倒在混凝土板上开始尸检时，他被其中包含的恐怖景象震住了。
He had never come across a case like it. Inside was the body of a young male adult. His abdominal and chest cavity had been emptied of all internal organs, which were nowhere to be found. His arms had been cut off at the sockets and legs at the pelvis, then stripped of skin and muscle. The limbs had then been placed into a plastic bag and inserted into the cavity in the chest. Skin-bearing identifying tattoos had not been discarded, but had instead been retained and placed in the torso as well. Also inside the cavity was a small plastic bag containing severed fingers and dissected genital organs. One testicle was missing.
他从未遇到过这样的案件。里面是一具年轻成年男子的尸体。他的腹腔和胸腔已被掏空，所有内脏都不翼而飞。他的手臂从肩窝处被切断，双腿从骨盆处被切断，随后剥去了皮和肉。四肢随后被放入一个塑料袋中，并塞进胸腔。带有可辨认纹身的皮肤并没有被丢弃，而是被保留下来并同样放置在躯干内。腔体内还有一个小塑料袋，里面装着被割断的手指和被解剖的生殖器官。少了一个睾丸。
Investigators theorised that might have been eaten by the man's killer or kept as a trophy. The victim also had injuries consistent with anal intercourse or an object being forced into the anus. He had been decapitated, with bite marks present on the vertebra where the head had been cut away by a sharp instrument. Bite marks were also apparent where the legs had been separated from the torso. The young male's head was affixed to the sternum by a yellow rope that went through his mouth and out the neck and then wrapped around his chest. A time of death was difficult to ascertain, but the body's condition indicated that it hadn't been immersed in the water for very long. 24 hours before discovery was a rough estimate. The mutilation was so involved it could have taken anywhere from three to six hours to complete.
调查人员推测，那可能被凶手吃掉了，或者是作为战利品保留了下来。受害者身上还有与肛交或异物强行塞入肛门相符的伤势。他被斩首，头部被利器切除的脊椎骨上有咬痕。腿部与躯干分离的地方也留有明显的咬痕。这名年轻男子的头部用一根黄色绳子固定在胸骨上，绳子穿过他的嘴巴并从颈部穿出，然后缠绕在他的胸部。死亡时间很难确定，但尸体的状况表明它浸泡在水中的时间并不长。粗略估计是在被发现前 24 小时。这种肢解手段极其复杂，可能需要三到六个小时才能完成。
The killer had, at the very least, a basic medical background. The dissection, particularly of the hands and thigh bones, had been done by someone with a definite knowledge of anatomy and surgical skill. Extracting prints from the severed fingers, the major crime squad were able to identify the victim. 25-year-old Neil Muir lived a transient life. He spent his childhood in rural South Australia before moving to Adelaide in his teens. Known as a country boy and a bit of a loner, the friends he did make introduced him to drugs. By August 1978, Neil was unemployed and lived alone in a boarding house in Adelaide. Neil was trying hard to beat his heroin addiction and was enrolled in the methadone program at Hillcrest Hospital.
凶手至少具备基础的医学背景。这种解剖，尤其是对手部和大腿骨的解剖，是由一个对解剖学有着明确知识和外科技术的人完成的。重大案件调查组通过从被割断的手指提取指纹，成功确认了受害者的身份。25 岁的尼尔·缪尔（Neil Muir）过着漂泊不定的生活。他的童年是在南澳大利亚州乡村度过的，十几岁时搬到了阿德莱德。作为一名乡村男孩，他有点独来独往，他结交的朋友将他引入了毒品世界。到 1978 年 8 月，尼尔失业了，独自住在阿德莱德的一家寄宿公寓里。尼尔正努力戒除海洛因瘾，并在希尔克雷斯特医院（Hillcrest Hospital）参加美沙酮治疗项目。
Neil attended his scheduled appointments on the weekend of August 25 and 26. At his last appointment, Neil was seen leaving the clinic and getting into a car with an unknown male driver. He was wearing a bone-colored, bulky-knit cardigan with black stripes, light-colored corduroy jeans, an ebony bangle, a sleeper earring in one ear and a drop-style earring in the other. He was also carrying a flick knife. Two days later, his mutilated remains were found floating in the waters off a mudden curve. Neil Muir's murder bore a disturbing similarity to the Allen Barnes case. Both young men had sustained extensive anal injuries prior to their deaths.
尼尔在 8 月 25 日和 26 日的周末按时参加了预约。在他的最后一次预约中，尼尔被看到离开诊所，上了一辆由一名身份不明的男性司机驾驶的汽车。他当时身穿一件米色、粗织、带黑色条纹的开衫，浅色灯芯绒牛仔裤，戴着一个乌木手镯，一只耳朵上戴着弹簧耳环（sleeper earring），另一只耳朵上戴着水滴形耳环。他还随身携带了一把弹簧刀。两天后，他被肢解的残骸被发现在马登湾（mudden curve，应为 Mutton Cove 的误读）附近的水面上漂浮。尼尔·缪尔谋杀案与阿兰·巴恩斯案有着令人不安的相似之处。两名年轻男子在死前都遭受了广泛的肛门损伤。
It was unclear if Neil had been drugged like Allen, as his stomach was missing so its contents couldn't be tested. However, several recent injection sites were found on skin believed to have come from his right arm. Neil also had a wound on his scalp, not a fatal blow, but enough to render him incapacitated. However, there were also numerous differences between the two murders, most notably the condition in which the bodies were found. Given Neil's heroin addiction, detectives theorized that his death was unrelated to Allen Barnes. The gruesome manner in which Neil was treated seemed to be a warning. One drug scene contact for the advertiser newspaper said that Neil was, quote, a small-time nobody, someone who didn't matter.
目前尚不清楚尼尔是否像阿兰那样被下药，因为他的胃不见了，所以无法对其内容物进行检测。然而，在被认为来自他右臂的皮肤上发现了几个最近的注射点。尼尔头皮上也有伤口，虽非致命一击，但也足以让他失去行动能力。然而，这两起谋杀案之间也存在许多差异，最显著的是发现尸体时的状况。鉴于尼尔有海洛因瘾，侦探们推测他的死与阿兰·巴恩斯无关。尼尔遭受的这种骇人听闻的对待似乎是一种警告。《广告人报》（The Advertiser）的一位毒品圈联系人说，尼尔是，引述，“一个无足轻重的小人物，一个无所谓的人。”
Perhaps that is why he was selected for this type of killing, to show the druggies that no one gets away without paying. This theory was reinforced by the fact that Neil's fingers and tattooed skin were intentionally stored with his body, as though the killer wanted his identity known. Associates of Neil speculated that he had to have either been dealing drugs himself or turning to sex work to cover the costs of his addiction. Divers scoured the Port Adelaide River to find Neil's internal organs, but were unsuccessful. Police speculated that, like Allen Barnes, Neil had been killed elsewhere and driven to water. A policeman present at Neil's autopsy told the advertiser, wherever he was killed and cut up must have been like a slaughterhouse by the time it was over. Detective Lee Haddon was placed in charge of the Neil Muir murder investigation.
也许这就是为什么他被选为这种杀戮的目标，以此向瘾君子们表明，没有人能不付代价就逃脱。尼尔的手指和带有纹身的皮肤被刻意与他的尸体存放在一起，这一事实强化了这种推测，就好像凶手希望人们知道他的身份一样。尼尔的熟人推测，他要么自己一直在贩毒，要么转向性交易来支付他的毒瘾费用。潜水员在阿德莱德港河中搜寻尼尔的内脏，但没有成功。警方推测，和阿兰·巴恩斯一样，尼尔在别处被杀害后被用车运到了水边。一名出席尼尔尸检的警察告诉《广告人报》，无论他在哪里被杀害和分尸，等一切结束时，现场一定就像个屠宰场。侦探李·哈登（Lee Haddon）被任命负责尼尔·缪尔谋杀案的调查。
Haddon turned to criminal profiling to understand the type of person capable of committing such a sickening act. A police psychologist concluded that the offender was either mentally ill or an extremely sadistic psychopath. They might not openly display aggression, but instead portray themselves as polite, gentle and neat, while secretly harboring strong and out of control sexual urges. Three days after Neil Muir's body was found, a doctor named Peter Milhouse checked himself into a rehabilitation clinic. When speaking with the admitting nurse, Milhouse revealed that he was an alcoholic and had been on a downward spiral since the beginning of the week when he'd gone on a bander. He also cited the fact that he was gay, had increasing debt and was currently being investigated for writing illegal prescriptions as adding to his depression and drinking problem. Two days later, while Dr Peter Milhouse was recuperating, he was paid a visit by Detective Lee Haddon. Haddon had received anonymous tip-offs about the 45-year-old GP, described as a nonviolent, quiet man who kept to himself.
哈登转向犯罪心理画像，以了解能够犯下如此令人作呕的行为的人究竟是何种类型。一名警察心理学家得出结论，罪犯要么患有精神疾病，要么是一个极其虐待狂的精神病态者。他们可能不会公开表现出攻击性，而是将自己描绘成礼貌、温和和整洁的人，同时内心却暗藏着强烈且失控的性冲动。在尼尔·缪尔的尸体被发现三天后，一位名叫彼得·米尔豪斯（Peter Milhouse）的医生住进了一家康复诊所。在与收治护士交谈时，米尔豪斯透露他是个酒鬼，并且自本周初开始狂饮以来一直在走下坡路。他还提到自己是同性恋、债务不断增加，目前正因开具非法处方而受到调查，这些都加重了他的抑郁和饮酒问题。两天后，正在康复中的彼得·米尔豪斯医生迎来了侦探李·哈登的拜访。哈登收到了关于这位 45 岁全科医生的匿名举报，他被描述为一个不暴力、安静、独来独往的人。
Peter Milhouse spent his weekends in hotels in Central Adelaide, hoping to hook up for a night of casual sex. Sources revealed that Milhouse was often seen in pubs and clubs with Neil Muir. Witness accounts indicated the pair had known each other for four years. It was uncertain whether they were just friends, or if Neil was getting drugs or money from the doctor in return for sexual favours. Detectives suspected this could be a possibility, as Peter Milhouse had previously been questioned by the drug squad for writing false prescriptions in return for sex. When confronted by police, Milhouse denied knowing Neil and produced a pre-written letter he had signed. It stated that he wouldn't answer any questions unless in the company of his lawyer. According to Youngblood by Detective Bobo Bryan, sources confirmed that Neil Muir and Dr Peter Milhouse would often drink together at the Hopin Sports & Social Club in Ridleyton, north of Adelaide.
彼得·米尔豪斯周末会在阿德莱德市中心的酒店度过，希望能勾搭上一晚的艳遇。消息人士透露，米尔豪斯经常被看到与尼尔·缪尔一起出入酒吧和俱乐部。目击者的陈述表明，两人已经认识四年了。目前尚不确定他们只是朋友，还是尼尔为了换取性服务而从医生那里获取毒品或金钱。侦探们怀疑这并非不可能，因为彼得·米尔豪斯此前曾因开假处方换取性服务而受到缉毒组的盘问。面对警方质问时，米尔豪斯否认认识尼尔，并出示了一封他已签署的预写信件。信中称，除非有他的律师在场，否则他不会回答任何问题。根据侦探博博·布莱恩（Bobo Bryan）所著的《血气方刚》（Youngblood），消息人士证实，尼尔·缪尔和彼得·米尔豪斯医生经常在阿德莱德以北里德利顿（Ridleyton）的霍平体育与社交俱乐部（Hopin Sports & Social Club）一起喝酒。
Detective Lee Haddon visited the establishment. Neil's associates at the social club said that they had last seen the pair drinking there on Sunday, August 26, the day Neil was thought to have disappeared. They told Detective Haddon to also visit the Mediterranean Hotel on Hindley Street, another city-based hangout spot for the two. Detective Lee Haddon spoke to a bouncer there who knew Neil well. He said that Neil had been at the hotel on the Thursday and Friday nights before he disappeared. On both occasions, he was in the company of Dr Peter Milhouse. The pair had been drinking schooners at their regular table next to the jukebox. Neil had also visited the bar by himself at lunchtime the day before his body was discovered.
侦探李·哈登走访了这家机构。尼尔在该社交俱乐部的熟人表示，他们最后一次看到两人在那里喝酒是在 8 月 26 日星期日，也就是尼尔被认为失踪的那天。他们告诉李·哈登侦探，也去顺便看看位于欣德利街（Hindley Street）的地中海酒店（Mediterranean Hotel），那是这两人在市内的另一个常去聚会点。侦探李·哈登与那里的一名很了解尼尔的保镖交谈。他说，尼尔在失踪前的周四和周五晚上都在这家酒店。在这两个场合，他都与彼得·米尔豪斯医生在一起。两人一直在点唱机旁边的固定座位上喝大杯啤酒（schooners）。在发现尸体的前一天午餐时间，尼尔还独自一人去过酒吧。
He had been wearing brown corduroy jeans with a long-sleeved shirt and drank schooners of beer well into the evening. A waitress complained to the bouncer that Neil had fallen asleep at the table and he was escorted out of the hotel. Neil left without incident, telling the bouncer, I'm going, mate, I'm going. Neil staggered down Hindley Street, where Dr Peter Milhouse would stay when visiting the city. He walked towards Moorford Street, disappearing into the night. On November 20, 1979, Detective Lee Haddon and two others drove to the small waterfront town of Wyalla, nearly 400 kilometres from Adelaide. Peter Milhouse was out of rehabilitation and was working there as a locum GP.
他穿着一条棕色灯芯绒牛仔裤，搭配一件长袖衬衫，一直喝大杯啤酒到深夜。一名女服务员向保镖抱怨尼尔在桌子旁睡着了，随后他被护送出了酒店。尼尔离开时没有发生冲突，他对保镖说：“我要走了，伙计，我要走了。”尼尔蹒跚着走下欣德利街，彼得·米尔豪斯医生在城里访问时就住在那里。他朝莫尔福德街（Moorford Street）走去，消失在夜色中。1979 年 11 月 20 日，侦探李·哈登和其他两人驱车前往距离阿德莱德近 400 公里的海滨小镇怀阿拉（Wyalla）。彼得·米尔豪斯已经结束康复，并在那里担任代班全科医生。
The detectives found him staying at a local hotel and arrested him over the misuse of prescriptions. On the four-hour drive back to Adelaide, Detective Haddon tried to build rapport and get Milhouse to discuss Neil Moor. He exercised his right to remain silent and was released pending trial. By this stage, detectives had searched Milhouse's North Adelaide residence. He lived by himself and kept the place untidy. Initial testing came back positive for blood on the bathroom floor. However, the area had been cleaned so thoroughly with chemicals that further analysis was not possible. In the kitchen were the same type of garbage bags used to dispose of Neil's body.
侦探们发现他住在当地的一家酒店，并因滥用处方将他逮捕。在驱车四个小时返回阿德莱德的途中，哈登侦探试图建立融洽关系，让米尔豪斯谈论尼尔·莫尔（Neil Moor，应为 Neil Muir 的拼写笔误）。但他行使了保持沉默的权利，并在候审期间被保释。在此阶段，侦探们搜查了米尔豪斯位于阿德莱德北部的住所。他一个人住，把地方弄得乱七八糟。初步检测结果显示浴室地板上有血迹反应。然而，该区域被化学物质彻底清洗过，以至于无法进行进一步分析。厨房里放着用来处理尼尔尸体的同款垃圾袋。
Outside, a clothesline known for having a distinctive yellow rope had been replaced with metal twine. The plastic bag containing Neil Moor's limbs contained a bandaid with tiny fibres stuck to its adhesive glue. Matching fibres were found on a rug in Dr Peter Milhouse's house. Though, it couldn't be proven the fibres on the bandaid came from that particular rug. The abundance of circumstantial evidence was enough for detectives to arrest Milhouse for the murder of Neil Moor in January 1980. The next day, he appeared in the Adelaide Magistrates Court where he was refused bail. The trial began the following year in September. Milhouse gave three days of sworn evidence and agreed to be cross-examined by the prosecution in an attempt to clear his name.
在外面，一根以悬挂独特黄绳而闻名的晾衣绳被金属麻绳取代了。装着尼尔·莫尔四肢的塑料袋里有一个创可贴，其粘合胶上粘着微小的纤维。在彼得·米尔豪斯医生家的地毯上也发现了相匹配的纤维。不过，无法证明创可贴上的纤维来自那张特定的地毯。丰富的间接证据足以让侦探们在 1980 年 1 月以谋杀尼尔·莫尔的罪名逮捕米尔豪斯。第二天，他出现在阿德莱德地方法院（Adelaide Magistrates Court），并被拒绝保释。审判于次年 9 月开始。米尔豪斯进行了为期三天的宣誓作证，并同意接受控方的盘问，以试图洗清自己的罪名。
He told the court that on the day of Neil's murder he had visited four separate hotels. Aside from that, he spent the week indoors. He stated that he had only heard of Neil's death when he read about it in the paper two days after his body was discovered. Milhouse claimed that even though he had degrees in medicine and surgery, he did not have the necessary knowledge of dissection to have carried out the mutilation of Neil Moor's body. An earlier committal hearing had established that the dissection of Neil Moor's body was likely carried out by someone with surgical expertise. Milhouse counted that he was a mediocre medical student, had done very little surgery as an intern at the Adelaide Children's Hospital, and that he had never performed a post-mortem.
他向法庭供称，在尼尔被谋杀当天，他去了四家不同的酒店。除此之外，他整个星期都待在室内。他声称，他直到在尸体被发现两天后在报纸上读到相关报道，才知道尼尔的死讯。米尔豪斯声称，尽管他拥有医学和外科学位，但他并不具备进行肢解尼尔·莫尔尸体所需的解剖知识。早期的听证会已经确定，对尼尔·莫尔尸体的解剖很可能由具有外科专业知识的人执行。米尔豪斯反驳说，他曾是一名平庸的医学生，在阿德莱德儿童医院（Adelaide Children's Hospital）实习期间做过很少的外科手术，并且他从未做过尸检。
The prosecution gave two possible motives for the murder of Neil Moor by Peter Milhouse. It might have been a murder committed out of contempt, or it was an accident, and Milhouse mutilated Neil's body to dispose of it. In summing up, the defense argued that the prosecution had not proved its case, and that it was dangerous for a jury to accept circumstantial evidence as fact. After 24 days of testimony and 98 witnesses, the jury deliberated for 75 minutes. They found the defendant not guilty. As he walked out of the courtroom, Dr Peter Milhouse hugged his mother and said, I am glad to see justice has been done.
控方提出了彼得·米尔豪斯谋杀尼尔·莫尔的两种可能动机。这可能是一起出于蔑视而实施的谋杀，或者是一场意外，米尔豪斯为了处理尸体而将其肢解。在总结陈词中，辩方辩称控方并未证明其指控，陪审团将间接证据视为事实是危险的。在经历了 24 天的证词和 98 名证人后，陪审团商议了 75 分钟。他们裁定被告无罪。当他走出法庭时，彼得·米尔豪斯医生拥抱了他的母亲，并说道：“我很高兴看到正义得到了伸张。”
The arrest and subsequent trial had lasting ramifications for Milhouse. The media reported extensively on aspects of his sex life, including the time he asked Neil to urinate on him in exchange for methadone. Yet, Milhouse had been cleared by a court of law, and by the end of 1980, detectives were no closer to making any further arrests. On the morning of Thursday, August 27, 1981, 14-year-old Peter Stognef was excited. After putting on his school uniform and collecting his bag, he left home. But instead of heading to school as expected, he walked to a nearby shopping mall. When the coast was clear, he returned home, dumping his school bag in the garage before getting changed. He was due to meet his friend, Daniel Saganoff, by the Silver Balls sculpture in Rundlemore, Adelaide's central hub for shopping.
这次逮捕和随后的审判对米尔豪斯产生了持久的影响。媒体广泛报道了他性生活的方方面面，包括他曾要求尼尔向他小便以换取美沙酮的事。然而，米尔豪斯已经被法庭宣判无罪，到 1980 年底，侦探们距离进行任何进一步逮捕并没有更近一步。1981 年 8 月 27 日星期四清晨，14 岁的彼得·斯托涅夫（Peter Stognef）兴奋不已。穿上校服并收好书包后，他离开了家。但他没有像平时那样去学校，而是步行去了附近的一个购物中心。确定四下无人后，他回到家，把书包扔在车库里，然后换了衣服。他本应在阿德莱德的中央购物中心朗德莫尔（Rundlemore）的银球雕塑（Silver Balls sculpture）旁与他的朋友丹尼尔·萨加诺夫（Daniel Saganoff）会面。
The pair had planned to whack school together, and Daniel said he might even have two girls with him. Peter was looking forward to spending the day with them. However, Daniel never followed through with the plan and didn't show up at Rundlemore. Despite this, Peter committed himself to ditching school and continued his day out alone. That same morning, Glenis Richardson was sipping coffee at a cafe in the Tea Tree Plaza, 15km northeast of Rundlemore. At around midday, she noticed something very odd. A teen fitting Peter Stognef's description was walking with a broad-framed, tanned-skinned man wearing a bomber jacket and trendy shoes. He appeared to be around 26 years old.
两人原计划一起逃学，丹尼尔说他甚至可能会带两个女孩一起去。彼得非常期待和她们一起度过这一天。然而，丹尼尔并没有兑现计划，也没有在朗德莫尔出现。尽管如此，彼得还是决定逃学，独自继续他的一天外出。当天早上，格伦尼斯·理查森（Glenis Richardson）正在距离朗德莫尔东北 15 公里处的茶树广场（Tea Tree Plaza）的一家咖啡馆里啜饮咖啡。大约在中午时分，她注意到了一件非常奇怪的事情。一个符合彼得·斯托涅夫特征的少年正与一个身材魁梧、皮肤黝黑、穿着飞行员夹克和时尚鞋子的男人一起散步。他看起来大约 26 岁。
While the scene itself wasn't out of the ordinary, the vibe between the two suggested to Glenis that something wasn't quite right. The Tea Tree Plaza was near Peter's family home in Hope Valley. Peter didn't return home that night. Police appealed for anyone who had seen the blue-eyed teen with the freckled face to come forward. Weeks passed with no sign of Peter, but something strange emerged months later. An off-duty police officer was scanning the shelves of the Tea Tree Gully Library when he picked up a book titled The Man Who Killed Boys about serial killer John Wayne Gacy. Thumbing through it, he noticed two blood-smeared pages towards the front of the book. Given the library's proximity to Peter Stognef's house, he turned it into the local police.
虽然这一幕本身并不罕见，但两人之间的氛围让格伦尼斯觉得有些不对劲。茶树广场靠近彼得在希望谷（Hope Valley）的家人住所。彼得那天晚上没有回家。警方呼吁任何见过这名有着雀斑脸的蓝眼睛少年的知情者站出来提供线索。几周过去了，依然没有彼得的踪迹，但在几个月后却出现了一件奇怪的事情。一名休班警察正在茶树加利图书馆（Tea Tree Gully Library）的书架间浏览，他拿起了一本名为《杀害男孩的男人》（The Man Who Killed Boys）的书，内容是关于连环杀手约翰·韦恩·加西（John Wayne Gacy）。翻阅时，他注意到书本前部有两页沾满了血迹。鉴于该图书馆距离彼得·斯托涅夫的家很近，他将这本书交给了当地警方。
Though, a connection was never established between the blood-stained book and the missing teen. Meanwhile, detectives continued to follow up leads that streamed into a tip-line, but were forced to concede that Peter Stognef had just vanished without a trace. 19-year-old Mark Langley was having a fantastic time at his friend's birthday party. Earlier that evening, on Saturday, February 27, 1982, Mark dressed in jeans and a blue satin shirt with a blue cardigan over the top. He finished off his look with his beloved silver chain with crab ingot to represent his star sign, Cancer. The party at Windsor Gardens, a northeastern suburb of Adelaide, had gone well into the night. It offered a reprieve from Mark's weekday work as a plumber, and he wasn't prepared to call it quits too early. At 1.15am, Mark and two friends decided to move on and continue their night out in the Adelaide CBD.
不过，这本血迹斑斑的书与失踪少年之间的联系始终未能确立。与此同时，侦探们继续跟进源源不断涌入热线电话的线索，但不得不承认彼得·斯托涅夫就这样人间蒸发了。19 岁的马克·兰利（Mark Langley）在朋友的生日派对上玩得十分开心。当天早些时候，即 1982 年 2 月 27 日星期六，马克穿着牛仔裤和一件蓝色缎面衬衫，外面套着一件蓝色开衫。他的造型以他心爱的银链收尾，链上挂着一只代表他星座——巨蟹座的螃蟹金条。派对在阿德莱德东北郊的温莎花园（Windsor Gardens）举行，一直持续到深夜。这让他得以从平日的管道工工作中解脱出来，而他不准备太早收场。凌晨 1.15 分，马克和两个朋友决定离开，去阿德莱德中央商务区继续他们的夜生活。
They piled into a car and made the journey into the warm and dry night. 15 minutes later, they pulled over on War Memorial Drive alongside the River Torrens. As the trio sat enjoying each other's company in the quiet and serene area, a minor argument broke out over cigarettes. Mark left the car in a half, deciding that he'd had enough and would walk home. Mark's friends drove off without him, but quickly had a change of heart and decided to go back for him. In order to return to where they left Mark, they had to complete a circuit, continuing down War Memorial Drive, crossing over the River Torrens near the Adelaide Zoo and driving along Victoria Drive before crossing the River Torrens again on King William Road Bridge.
他们挤进一辆车，驶入温暖干燥的夜色中。15 分钟后，他们将车停在托伦斯河（River Torrens）旁的战争纪念大道（War Memorial Drive）边。正当三人坐在这个安静祥和的区域享受彼此的陪伴时，为了一些香烟小事爆发了一场小争执。马克气冲冲地离开了车，决定自己受够了，要步行回家。马克的同伴们开车离去，但很快改变了主意，决定回头去找他。为了回到他们放下马克的地方，他们必须绕行一圈，沿战争纪念大道继续行驶，在阿德莱德动物园（Adelaide Zoo）附近穿过托伦斯河，沿着维多利亚大道（Victoria Drive）行驶，然后再次在威廉国王路桥（King William Road Bridge）上跨过托伦斯河。
The round trip took them 4 minutes. By the time they got back to their original location, Mark was gone. That night, Robert Windsor was driving along Hackney Street when he spotted a black-haired young man with a strong physique hitchhiking by the road. It was Mark Langley, though Robert didn't know the 19-year-old personally. Robert drove past Mark only to glance back at him in his rear-view mirror. He saw another car pull up and Robert assumed Mark climbed into it. The entire scenario was so brief and unremarkable, Robert didn't even take note of what the other vehicle looked like. The following morning, Mark's parents slept in. When they woke and realised their son hadn't returned home, they became worried.
这趟来回花了他门 4 分钟。当他们回到最初的地点时，马克已经不见了。那天晚上，罗伯特·温莎（Robert Windsor）开车经过哈克尼街（Hackney Street）时，发现路边有一个身材健壮、黑头发的年轻人在搭便车。那是马克·兰利，尽管罗伯特并不认识这名 19 岁的年轻人。罗伯特从马克身边开车驶过，只是从后视镜里回头看了一眼他。他看到另一辆车停了下来，罗伯特以为马克上那辆车了。整个场景是如此短暂且微不足道，罗伯特甚至没有注意另一辆车长什么样。第二天早上，马克的父母睡了个懒觉。当他们醒来发现儿子没有回家时，他们开始担心起来。
By midday, they had phoned the police, explaining that this behaviour was extremely out of character. Nine days passed. Then, in Summertime, 16km east of Adelaide, a farmer was poisoning blackberry bushes encroaching on his Sprig Road property. Within the invasive leafy bush, the farmer discovered the body of Mark Langley. He was clean and dressed in his jeans and blue woolen cardigan. Missing was his silk shirt and silver chain. Mark had likely died from major internal injuries caused by being anally assaulted with a bottle. A vertical incision ran down Mark's lower abdomen from underneath his belly button to the top of his pubic region, a length of 16.5cm.
到中午时分，他们已经报了警，并解释说这种行为极不符合他的性格。九天过去了。随后，在距离阿德莱德以东 16 公里处的萨默维尔（Summertime），一名农民正在他的斯普里格路（Sprig Road）房产上毒杀侵入的黑莓灌木。在入侵的叶茂灌木丛中，这位农民发现了马克·兰利的尸体。他身体干净，穿着牛仔裤和蓝色羊毛开衫。不见了的是他的丝绸衬衫和银项链。马克很可能是死于被瓶子肛交造成的重大内部伤害。一条垂直的切口从马克肚脐下方一直延伸到耻骨上部，长达 16.5 厘米。
Like a surgical procedure, the area had been shaved and the incision had been crudely but surgically sutured closed with thread and covered with surgical tape. Sections of bowel had been removed via the incision. A pathologist reasoned that the bottle had been inserted deep into the rectum to the point where it could only be retrieved surgically. It was likely the object contained evidence that could identify the killer, so they removed it completely. The presence of alcohol and prescription medication were found in Mark's bloodstream. The chemicals, methacwalone and diphenhydramine were the active ingredients in the drug mandrax, a sedative and hypnotic medication used to treat insomnia. A time of death was difficult to ascertain due to the level of decomposition. It was estimated that Mark had been murdered soon after his abduction.
就像外科手术一样，该区域被剃光了毛发，切口被粗糙但符合外科手术方式地用线缝合起来，并用手术胶带覆盖。部分肠道通过切口被移除。病理学家推断，瓶子被深深插入直肠，达到了只能通过手术取出的地步。该物品很可能包含可以识别凶手的证据，因此他们将其完全移除了。马克的血流中存在酒精和处方药。化学成分甲喹酮（methaqualone）和苯海拉明（diphenhydramine）是药物安眠酮（mandrax）的活性成分，这是一种用于治疗失眠的镇静和催眠药物。由于尸体腐烂程度较深，死亡时间很难确定。据估计，马克在被绑架后不久就被杀害了。
It was now becoming clear that there was a serial killer active in South Australia. Although initially reluctant to draw a concrete connection between the murders of Alan Barnes and Neil Muir over two years earlier, the discovery of Mark Langley's body established a disturbing pattern. An unknown assailant was abducting young men off Adelaide streets, violently sexually assaulting them, before murdering them and in several cases mutilating their remains. The victim's body would then be dumped in a secluded spot in the city's outskirts. Smoke wafted into the skies above two wells on June 23, 1982. In the town, located 40 kilometres north of Adelaide, a farmer was conducting a burn-off on his property on Middle Beach Road. Afterward, as he walked through the burnt landscape, he came across a blackened human skeleton in the ashes. The body had likely been dumped from the dirt road as it came to rest along the barbed wire fence line boundary of the farmer's property.
现在越来越明显的是，南澳大利亚州活跃着一名连环杀手。尽管最初不愿将两多年前阿兰·巴恩斯和尼尔·缪尔的谋杀案联系起来，但马克·兰利尸体的发现确立了一种令人不安的模式。一个未知的袭击者从阿德莱德街头绑架年轻男子，对他们进行残暴的性侵犯，然后将其杀害，并在数起案件中残害他们的遗体。受害者的尸体随后被抛弃在城市郊区的偏僻地点。1982 年 6 月 23 日，浓烟飘向双井（Two Wells）上方的天空。在这个位于阿德莱德以北 40 公里的小镇里，一名农民正在他位于中海滩路（Middle Beach Road）的房产上进行焚烧清理。事后，当他走过被烧焦的景观时，他在灰烬中偶然发现了一具被烧焦的人类骨骼。尸体很可能是从土路上被抛下的，因为它停在了农民房产边界的带刺铁丝网栅栏线旁。
The male skeleton's spinal cord had been severed with a saw, as had the legs above the knees. The legs were missing. Although not much more could be ascertained due to the accidental burning of the body, the dissection of the bones drew parallels to the mutilation of Neil Muir. Using skull shape and size, as well as dental records, the skeleton was confirmed to be that of missing 14-year-old Peter Stognef. Last seen on the day he wagged school 10 months earlier. Almost a year later, on Sunday June 5, 1983, Richard Colvin absentmindedly played with his pet dog's chrome-studded collar. In his other hand was a telephone receiver. Speaking down the line was his girlfriend, Brigida, who Richard spoke to on the phone every day.
这具男性骨骼的脊髓被锯子切断，膝盖以上的双腿也是如此。双腿不见了。尽管由于尸体被意外烧毁而无法查明更多信息，但对骨头的解剖与对尼尔·缪尔的残害有相似之处。通过头骨的形状和大小以及牙科记录，这具骨架被证实属于失踪的 14 岁少年彼得·斯托涅夫。他最后一次被人看到是在 10 个月前他逃学的那天。近一年后的 1983 年 6 月 5 日星期日，理查德·科尔文（Richard Colvin）漫不经心地玩弄着他宠物狗镶有铬钉的项链。他手里拿着电话听筒。电话那头说话的是他的女朋友布里吉达（Brigida），理查德每天都给她打电话。
Although they had only been dating a month, Richard loved Brigida and the pair talked about getting engaged when they turned 19 in four years time. It was getting late in the afternoon when Richard told Brigida that he planned to meet up with his friend Carl to kick the footy. He said he would call her the moment he got back. Richard and Carl visited the local park in North Adelaide, two kilometres north of the River Torrens. Athletic, fit and tall for his age at 180cm, Richard enjoyed getting out and being active on the weekends. He took his dog's collar with him and put it around his neck. It stood out against the rest of his outfit consisting of blue jeans, Adidas sneakers and navy blue t-shirt featuring the logo for television station Channel 9. As 6pm drew near, Richard walked his friend Carl to the nearest bus stop on O'Connell Street.
虽然他们才交往了一个月，但理查德深爱着布里吉达，两人还谈到等四年后他们 18 岁时订婚的事。天色渐晚，理查德告诉布里吉达，他打算和他的朋友卡尔（Carl）见面去踢足球。他说他一回去就会给她打电话。理查德和卡尔去了位于阿德莱德北部的当地公园，距离托伦斯河以北两公里。理查德身材健美，身高 180 厘米，对于他的年龄来说算很高了，他喜欢在周末外出活动。他把狗的项链随身带走，并把它戴在脖子上。这与他其余的着装形成了鲜明对比，他穿着蓝色牛仔裤、阿迪达斯运动鞋和一件印有 9 号电视台（Channel 9）标志的海军蓝色 T 恤。随着下午 6 点临近，理查德陪着他的朋友卡尔走到奥康奈尔街（O'Connell Street）最近的公交车站。
As mentioned in the book Young Blood by Detective Bob O'Brien, Carl suggested that they walk to the King William Road bus stop instead near the Women and Children's Hospital. But Richard dissuaded him, he felt it would be unsafe to cross the darkened parkland to get there. While they waited for the bus, Richard asked Carl what he thought of his dog collar accessory. Carl told him it looked stupid and in response Richard took it off and tied it around his wrist instead. Carl boarded the next bus and Richard set off along the busy street to his family townhouse, approximately 300 metres away. 50 metres from Richard's home lived a man who worked as a security guard. Suffering from a bout of the flu, he went to bed early that evening, only to be woken up at around 6.15pm. Someone outside was crying for help.
正如侦探鲍勃·奥布莱恩（Bob O'Brien）所著的《年轻血统》（Young Blood）一书中所提到的，卡尔建议他们改为步行去妇女儿童医院（Women and Children's Hospital）附近的威廉国王路公交车站。但理查德劝阻了他，他觉得穿过昏暗的公园去那里不安全。在等公交车时，理查德问卡尔对他戴的狗项链配饰有什么看法。卡尔告诉他看起来很蠢，作为回应，理查德把它摘下来，改系在手腕上。卡尔上了下一班公交车，理查德则沿着繁华的街道动身前往他大约 300 米外的家族联排别墅。距离理查德家 50 米的地方住着一名担任保安的男子。由于患流感，他那天晚上很早就上床睡觉了，结果在晚上 6 点 15 分左右被吵醒了。外面有人在呼救。
He then heard the sound of car doors banging, followed by a loud exhaust as a car accelerated away. The security guard didn't think anything of it at the time and drifted back to sleep. Days later, detectives showed up at his house. They were door-knocking the area in search of 15-year-old Richard Kelvin, who failed to return home two days earlier after visiting the local park with a friend. The security guard told the detectives of the cries for help and the accelerating car he heard that night. Being a car enthusiast, he was able to identify the vehicle's exhaust as sounding like it belonged to a Holden with a faulty muffler. Richard's father's celebrity status ensured the teen's unexplained disappearance drew a large amount of police and media focus. Rob Kelvin was a newsreader for Channel 9.
接着，他听到车门砰地关上的声音，随后是一阵刺耳的排气声，一辆车加速驶离。当时保安并没有多想，又迷迷糊糊地睡着了。几天后，侦探们出现在他家门口。他们在该地区挨家挨户敲门，寻找 15 岁的理查德·凯尔文（Richard Kelvin），他两天前去当地公园和一个朋友见面后未能回家。保安向侦探们讲述了他那天晚上听到的呼救声和加速的汽车。作为一个汽车爱好者，他能够辨认出这辆车的排气声音听起来像是一辆消音器有故障的霍顿汽车。理查德父亲的名人身份确保了这名少年的离奇失踪引起了警方和媒体的大量关注。罗布·凯尔文（Rob Kelvin）是 9 号电视台的新闻主播。
A professional with a strong temperament, Rob continued to present the news each night despite the overwhelming distress he faced off camera. He stopped short of reading out any reports regarding his missing son. By the time Richard Kelvin vanished, South Australia's major crimes unit was overwhelmed and their resources were stretched. They were still investigating the murders of Alan Barnes, Neil Muir, Mark Langley and Peter Stognaff. Other urgent investigations were also underway, including the search for 10-year-old Louise Bell, who was abducted from her home in Hackham West four months earlier. Louise's story is covered in episode 105 of Case File. In Richard's case, they immediately suspected he had met with foul play. They even collected one of his schoolbooks to compare handwriting samples against any ransom letters they might receive from a kidnapper targeting Richard's high-profile father.
作为一个性格坚韧的专业人士，罗布尽管面临着镜头外无法承受的痛苦，但每晚仍继续播音新闻。他唯独没有宣读任何关于他失踪儿子的报告。当理查德·凯尔文失踪时，南澳大利亚州的重大案件调查组已经不堪重负，他们的资源捉襟见肘。他们仍在调查阿兰·巴恩斯、尼尔·缪尔、马克·兰利和彼得·斯托涅夫的谋杀案。其他紧急调查也在进行中，包括搜寻 10 岁的路易丝·贝尔（Louise Bell），她在四个月前从哈卡姆韦斯特（Hackham West）的家中被绑架。路易丝的故事在《档案库》（Case File）第 105 集中有报道。在理查德的案子中，他们立即怀疑他遭遇了不测。他们甚至收集了他的一本课本，以便将笔迹样本与他们可能收到的来自针对理查德高知名度父亲的绑架者的任何勒索信进行比对。
Trevor Ford hosted a nightly talk-back segment on Adelaide radio station 5DN. In the aftermath of Richard Kelvin's disappearance, Trevor was live on air when a call came through from an unidentified male. He said that Richard was being held in a caravan in the Mount Crawford area of the Adelaide Hills before promptly hanging up. Given Mount Crawford's proximity to the locations of where Alan Barnes and Mark Langley's bodies were found, detectives thought this a worthwhile lead. An aerial search did locate a few run-down and abandoned caravans amongst the bushland, but all were empty. Soon after, the major crime squad received the telephone tip-off of their own. The male caller named two men, Mark and Doug, as being responsible for Richard's abduction. He said that they drove a light-colored 1963 E.J. Holden sedan.
特雷弗·福特（Trevor Ford）在阿德莱德 5DN 广播电台主持每晚的连线谈话节目（talk-back segment）。在理查德·凯尔文失踪后不久，特雷弗正在进行直播，此时接到了一名身份不明的男子的来电。他称理查德被关在阿德莱德山（Adelaide Hills）芒特克劳福德（Mount Crawford）地区的一辆大篷车里，随即便挂断了电话。鉴于芒特克劳福德距离发现阿兰·巴恩斯和马克·兰利尸体的地方很近，侦探们认为这是一条有价值的线索。空中搜寻确实在灌木丛中找到了一些破旧且被废弃的大篷车，但都是空的。不久之后，重大案件调查组接到了他们自己的电话举报。这名男性来电者点名了两个人，马克（Mark）和道格（Doug），称他们对理查德的绑架负责。他说他们开着一辆浅色的 1963 年产 EJ 霍顿轿车。
The vehicle was in good condition, fitted with a tow bar and two mirrors on the front guards. This make-and-model of car used to be very popular, however, over the years, the numbers on the road had dwindled, making it somewhat of a rarer vehicle. According to the book Youngblood, a full-page image of the car in question alongside a photo of Richard Kelvin was published in the advertiser newspaper. It failed to generate any worthwhile response, leading investigators to believe the entire story was a hoax. Seven weeks passed, and police were no closer to finding Richard. Situated 36km southeast of Adelaide City lies the small town of Kursbruck. In the heart of the sprawling Adelaide Hills region, Kursbruck is home to only a couple of hundred people. On Sunday, July 24, 1983, Kursbruck resident Trevor Holmes and his family took to the bush around their home in search of moss-covered stones to put in their garden.
这辆车状况良好，配有拖车杆和前挡泥板上的两个后视镜。这种品牌和型号的汽车过去非常受欢迎，然而多年来，路上的数量锐减，使其成为一种相对罕见的车辆。根据《杨布洛德》一书，该车的全页照片以及理查德·凯尔文的照片一起发表在《广告人报》上。但它未能产生任何有价值的反应，导致调查人员认为整个故事是一个恶作剧。七个星期过去了，警方距离找到理查德依然毫无进展。位于阿德莱德市东南36公里处坐落着一个小镇科斯布鲁克。在广阔的阿德莱德山地区的中心地带，科斯布鲁克只有几百名居民。1983年7月24日星期日，科斯布鲁克居民特雷弗·霍姆斯和他的家人来到他们家周围的灌木丛中，寻找长满青苔的石头放在他们的花园里。
Wandering away from his wife and children, Trevor came across some distinctive pale fragments on the ground. He thought they were kangaroo bones and inched closer to have a look. Suddenly, a person caught his eye. It was a young male with sandy blonde hair. He was lying in the nearby scrub on his left side and in the fetal position. Thinking that the man was injured, Trevor called out to him but was met with silence. Trevor approached and saw the Channel 9 logo on the man's shirt. A dog collar was fastened around his neck.
特雷弗离开妻子和孩子四处闲逛，在地上发现了一些独特的苍白碎片。他以为那是袋鼠的骨头，于是走近仔细观察。突然，一个人吸引了他的目光。那是一个留着沙金色头发的年轻男性。他侧卧在附近的灌木丛中，呈胎儿状。特雷弗以为这个人受伤了，便向他喊话，但只得到了沉默。特雷弗走近一看，发现这名男子的衬衫上有第九频道的标志。他的脖子上还套着一个狗项圈。
Trevor bent down, cleared the scrub away from the man's face and realized he had found the body of Richard Kelvin. An autopsy showed a subdural hemorrhage from a head injury that had occurred early on in Richard's abduction. This blow would have been enough to kill him but the partial resolution of the hemorrhage indicated that he had survived the attack. Bruising down Richard's back and buttocks were estimated to have been inflicted two weeks before his death. He also showed signs of anal trauma. Richard's body had been washed prior to being redressed and his captor had also given him a haircut. Unique fibers were found on Richard's clothing including his underwear. They came in a variety of colors, blue, turquoise, purple, orange, yellow, black, brown, red and green.
特雷弗弯下腰，将男子脸上的灌木丛清理干净，意识到他找到了理查德·凯尔文的尸体。尸检显示，头部受伤导致的硬膜下血肿发生在理查德被绑架的初期。这次打击本足以致命，但血肿的部分消退表明他在袭击中存活了下来。理查德背部和臀部的瘀伤据估计是在他死前两周造成的。他的身上还显示出肛门创伤的迹象。理查德的尸体在重新穿上衣服之前被清洗过，他的绑架者还给他剪了头发。在理查德的衣物（包括内衣）上发现了独特的纤维。它们的颜色多种多样，有蓝色、青色、紫色、橙色、黄色、黑色、棕色、红色和绿色。
Seven foreign human hairs were also found on the inside legs of Richard's jeans. Richard had been kept alive for up to five weeks before succumbing to blood loss. Traces of various sedatives including valium, amitul and rehypno were found in his system. As was mandrax, the drug also used to weaken Mark Langley. Richard had also been given alcohol laced with chloral hydrate like alum barns. Kersbrook was accessible via South Para Road which also led to the South Para Reservoir where alum barns was found. The strength required to throw alum barns' body over a metre high bridge railing, the extensive mutilation of Neil Muir's body, the surgical procedure performed on Mark Langley and the difficulties in keeping Richard Kelvin captive for five weeks,
在理查德牛仔裤的内侧裤腿上还发现了七根外来人类毛发。理查德在因失血过多而死之前，被维持生命长达五周。他的体内发现了各种镇静剂的痕迹，包括安定、阿米图尔和雷海普诺。还有安眠酮，这种药物也曾被用来削弱马克·朗利。理查德还被喂食了掺有水合氯醛的酒精，就像阿勒姆·巴恩斯一样。克尔斯布鲁克可以通过南帕拉路前往，这条路通往南帕拉水库，阿勒姆·巴恩斯就是在那里的水库被发现的。将阿勒姆·巴恩斯的尸体扔过一米多高的桥栏杆所需的体力，对尼尔·缪尔尸体的广泛残害，对马克·朗利实施的外科手术，以及将理查德·凯尔文囚禁五周的困难，
all pointed to more than one individual being responsible for the crimes. Detectives were certain that the young men were imprisoned and killed somewhere where large volumes of blood could be cleaned up easily, such as a factory, butcher's shop or somewhere with commercial cleaning facilities. Richard Kelvin was the killer's fifth known victim and with the discovery of his body, a wave of hysteria swept over Adelaide. Vigilantes patrolled the River Torrens keeping their eyes out for suspicious activity and to protect passers-by. The media did little to quell the overwhelming fear, with criminologist Dr Alan Perry warning that the publicity surrounding the case would be giving the perpetrator immense satisfaction. In an attempt to reassure the public, a detective appeared on current affairs program 60 minutes. He vowed that the police were taking every action to break up the happy family of murderers.
这一切都指向了不止一个人对这些罪行负责。侦探们确信，这些年轻人是被囚禁并杀害在某个可以轻易清理大量血液的地方，例如工厂、肉铺或拥有商业清洁设施的地方。理查德·凯尔文是凶手已知的第五名受害者，随着他尸体的发现，一股歇斯底里的情绪席卷了阿德莱德。治安维持会成员在托伦斯河沿岸巡逻，密切注视可疑活动以保护路人。媒体几乎没有平息这种压倒性的恐惧，犯罪学家艾伦·佩里博士警告说，围绕该案的宣传会给犯罪分子带来巨大的满足感。为了安抚公众，一名侦探出现在时事节目《60分钟》上。他发誓，警方正在采取一切行动来捣毁这个快乐的杀人犯家庭。
The remark led to the creation of the title the homicides would come to be known as The Family Murders. Mandrakes, also known as Quailudes, was a sedative and hypnotic medication commonly used to treat insomnia in the 70s. Taking the drug, particularly in doses above the recommended therapeutic range, caused the user to feel a rush of euphoria, relaxed mood and heightened sexual arousal. As such, the drug was known colloquially as Randy Mandy. Because of the potential for mandrakes to become abused and dependency to occur, in 1978, the drug came under stricter laws governing its prescription. As a result, the medication was prescribed much less frequently. Those that took mandrakes were not allowed to continue on it for more than two months without approval from the Central Board of Health. As Mark Langley and Richard Kelvin had been tranquilized with mandrakes,
这句话促成了后来被称为“家族谋杀案”的凶杀案称号的诞生。曼德克斯（Mandrakes），也被称为安眠酮（Quaaludes），是一种在70年代广泛用于治疗失眠的镇静和催眠药物。服用该药物，尤其是剂量超过推荐治疗范围时，会导致使用者感到一阵欣快感、放松的心情和高度的性兴奋。因此，该药物在俗语中被称为“兰迪·曼迪”（Randy Mandy）。由于曼德克斯有被滥用和产生依赖性的潜力，1978年，该药物受到了有关其处方的更严格法律的约束。因此，该药物的处方频率大大降低。未经中央卫生委员会批准，服用曼德克斯的人不得连续服用超过两个月。由于马克·朗利和理查德·凯尔文曾被曼德克斯麻醉，
detectives Trevor Kipling and Bob O'Brien visited the Adelaide Officers of the State Health Commission. The eight-story building held copies of all prescriptions for restricted drugs in South Australia. Working on a long shot, they began leaping through the thousands of scripts for mandrakes that were housed in large drawers. About an hour later, Trevor Kipling motioned to his partner to stop looking. He had a prescription in his hand. While the name didn't ring any bells to Bob O'Brien, Trevor remembered being told of an incident that had occurred ten months prior, on Saturday, September 11, 1982. Three months after Peter Stognaff's charred remains were found, a 36-year-old man was filling up an eski with ice at an icework on Lower Port Rush Road, near to where it crossed the River Torrens. A 16-year-old boy known as George suddenly caught his attention.
侦探特雷弗·基普林和鲍勃·奥布赖恩拜访了州卫生委员会的阿德莱德办公室。这座八层楼的建筑里保存着南澳大利亚州所有受管制药物的处方的副本。他们抱着渺茫的希望，开始翻阅存放在大抽屉里的成千上万份曼德克斯处方。大约一个小时后，特雷弗·基普林示意他的搭档停止寻找。他手里拿着一张处方。虽然这个名字对鲍勃·奥布赖恩来说很陌生，但特雷弗想起曾被告知十个月前发生的一起事件，那是在1982年9月11日星期六。在彼得·斯托格纳夫烧焦的遗体被发现三个月后，一名36岁的男子正在下波特路附近的一家制冰厂用冰块装满一个塑料保温箱，该地点靠近它穿过托伦斯河的地方。一个名叫乔治的16岁男孩突然引起了他的注意。
The teen was hitchhiking along the road and approaching where the man was waiting near his car. He offered George a ride and the pair then got into the man's bronze Ford Falcon. As mentioned in the book Youngblood, as the pair drove along, the man told George about a party. He said there would be alcohol and girls there, adding that they would have a great time. The man then drove George to a house. There was no wild party as he had promised, just a few women drinking. George was offered a drink which made him feel groggy. He was led into a bedroom by one of the women who took advantage of his vulnerable state, while the man who picked him up watched.
这名青少年正在路边搭便车，并走近男子在车旁等待的地方。他主动提出让乔治搭车，随后两人上了这名男子的古铜色福特猎鹰轿车。正如《杨布洛德》一书中提到的，当两人驱车前行时，男子向乔治讲述了一个派对。他说那里会有酒精和女孩，并补充说他们会玩得很开心。随后，男子开车将乔治带到了一栋房子里。这里并没有他承诺的狂欢派对，只有几个正在喝酒的女人。有人给乔治递了一杯饮料，这让他感到昏昏沉沉。其中一个女人把他领进了一间卧室，利用他虚弱的状态对他下手，而那个接他上车的男子则在一旁观看。
George then passed out. Two days later, George entered the Holden Hill Police Station in northeast Adelaide. His memory was hazy, though he was clearly distressed. George recalled hitchhiking home on Saturday night, the bronze Ford Falcon, the male driver, and the gathering at the house. 24 hours after arriving at the house, George was returned home in a taxi. A checkup by a doctor showed that he had suffered anal trauma. Sam Bass from the Holden Hill Crime Investigation Bureau spoke to the taxi driver who had driven George home on the night of the 11th. He then visited the pickup address in the metropolitan suburb of Alburton, a 20-minute drive from the city.
随后乔治昏了过去。两天后，乔治走进了阿德莱德东北部的霍登山警察局。他的记忆有些模糊，但显然非常痛苦。乔治回忆起周六晚上搭便车回家、古铜色的福特猎鹰轿车、男司机以及在房子里的聚会。在到达那栋房子24小时后，乔治坐出租车被送回了家。医生的检查显示他遭受了肛门创伤。霍登山犯罪调查局的萨姆·巴斯与11日晚送乔治回家的出租车司机进行了交谈。随后，他走访了位于阿尔伯顿大都市郊区的接驾地址，距离市中心有20分钟的车程。
The occupants of the slightly shabby but ordinary low-set home were questioned. Three people lived at the address, a man and two transgender women, one of whom for this episode we will refer to as Miss P. She was later arrested for the rape of George. However, the case against her was ultimately dismissed in the Port Adelaide Court when no evidence was brought forward. Miss P. and her housemates did name the man who had brought George to their doorstep, Bevan Spencer Von Einem. Officer Bass drove to Von Einem's workplace, Pipeline Supplies of Australia, to discuss the allegations levelled against him. He did not want to be spoken to at work, but agreed to be interviewed at the Holden Hill Police Station. Von Einem remembered the night in question, though maintained that George was more than willing to go to the party.
这栋略显破旧但很普通的平房里的住户受到了盘问。该地址住着三个人，一名男子和两名跨性别女性，本集我们将其中一人称为P小姐。她后来因涉嫌强奸乔治而被捕。然而，由于没有提出任何证据，阿德莱德地方法院最终驳回了对她的指控。P小姐和她的室友确实说出了将乔治带到他们家门口的那名男子的名字，他就是贝文·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆。巴斯警官开车前往冯·艾内姆的工作单位——澳大利亚管道供应公司，以讨论针对他的指控。他不想在工作场所谈论此事，但同意在霍尔登希尔警察局接受盘问。冯·艾内姆对当晚的事情记忆犹新，但他坚持认为乔治是完全自愿去参加派对的。
He alleged that after they arrived at approximately 1am, they listened to music. George drank beer and brandy while chatting to the house guests. Von Einem denied spiking any of George's drinks and stated that George willingly slept with Miss P. He also denied being in the bedroom with them at any time. Von Einem said that after the sexual encounter, Miss P. came out of her bedroom and fell asleep on the lounge while George slept in her bed. Von Einem went into the room and lay on top of the covers next to George. The pair slept late into the next afternoon. When they awoke, Von Einem claimed George had been too tired to shower from the night spent drinking.
他声称，他们在凌晨1点左右到达后便开始听音乐。乔治一边喝着啤酒和白兰地，一边与屋内的客人聊天。冯·艾内姆否认在乔治的任何饮品中下药，并表示乔治是自愿与P小姐发生关系的。他还否认自己曾在任何时候与他们一同呆在卧室里。冯·艾内姆说，性行为发生后，P小姐从她的卧室出来，在沙发上睡着了，而乔治则睡在她的床上。冯·艾内姆走进房间，躺在乔治身旁的被子上。两人一直睡到第二天下午很晚。他们醒来时，冯·艾内姆声称乔治因为昨晚喝了酒而太累，无法淋浴。
Von Einem then undressed the teen and washed him before sending him home in a taxi, handing the driver $15 and George's home address written on a scrap of paper. Detective Trevor Kipling was later told of this incident by a Holden Hill police officer. Even though George ultimately declined to press charges, Kipling had remembered the unusual name of his alleged assailant. Kipling looked down at the name on the mandrake's prescription in his hands. Bevan Spencer Von Einem Described as softly spoken, charming and intelligent, Bevan Spencer Von Einem was the apple of his mother's eye. He accompanied her to Tupperware parties, took her shopping and tended to her every need. He would even drive her to her cousin's place every second week where she would spend the weekend.
随后，冯·艾内姆脱下这名少年的衣服并为他清洗，然后叫了一辆出租车把他送回家，同时递给司机15美元以及写在纸条上的乔治的家庭住址。后来，一名霍尔登希尔的警察将这起事件告诉了侦探特雷弗·基普林。尽管乔治最终拒绝起诉，但基普林记住了他所谓袭击者的那个不寻常的名字。基普林看着手中曼德拉草处方上的名字。贝文·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆。贝文·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆被形容为温声细语、迷人且聪明，是母亲的心头肉。他陪母亲参加特百惠派对，带她去购物，照顾她的每一个需求。每隔一周，他甚至还会开车送母亲去她表姐家，母亲将在那里度过周末。
His mother's friends remarked that they wished they had a son like Bevan. Von Einem was musically gifted. A member of the Harp Society, Von Einem played regularly when he wasn't working at pipeline supplies of Australia. Employed there for 16 years, Von Einem had started as a bookkeeper before working his way up to the role of accountant. A valued and trusted employee, Von Einem had keys so he could gain access to the industrial building after hours. Von Einem was openly gay at a time when Australian society was intolerant towards same sex attracted people. He experienced the discrimination firsthand in 1972. At the time, the public toilets along the banks of the River Torrens were referred to as the number one beat, a place where gay men could meet and pick up other men.
他母亲的朋友们感叹说，他们希望能有这样一个像贝文一样的儿子。冯·艾内姆极具音乐天赋。作为竖琴协会的成员，冯·艾内姆在不为澳大利亚管道供应公司工作时经常弹奏竖琴。冯·艾内姆在那里工作了16年，最初是一名簿记员，后来晋升为会计。作为一名受人重视且值得信赖的员工，冯·艾内姆拥有钥匙，可以在非工作时间进入这座工业建筑。在澳大利亚社会对同性恋人群不那么宽容的年代，冯·艾内姆公开了自己的同性恋身份。他在1972年亲身经历了这种歧视。当时，托伦斯河岸边的公共厕所被称为一号约会点，是同性恋男子相遇并结识其他男子的场所。
The stigma attached to gay relationships at the time meant that those looking to meet there were subjected to not only attacks from the public, but also police officers. One such incident occurred in 1972. Roger James was standing by a bench that overlooked the river when he was set upon by police officers patrolling the number one beat. They pushed Roger into the water causing his leg to break on impact. He was soon joined by another man, Dr George Duncan, who the officers also shoved into the river. Roger surfaced and saw George struggling, but his injury prevented him from being able to help the university lecturer. Roger watched George slowly sink under water and drown. The police jeered at Roger, telling him to save his mate.
当时同性恋关系所背负的污名意味着，那些去那里寻找伴侣的人不仅会遭到公众的袭击，还会遭到警察的攻击。其中一起事件发生在1972年。罗杰·詹姆斯正站在俯瞰河流的长椅旁，突然遭到在巡逻一号约会点的警察的袭击。他们把罗杰推进水中，导致他的腿在落水时骨折。不久后，另一名男子乔治·邓肯博士也加入了进来，警察同样把他推进了河里。罗杰浮出水面，看到乔治在挣扎，但他的伤势使他无法帮助这位大学讲师。罗杰看着乔治慢慢沉入水底并溺水身亡。警察对罗杰冷嘲热讽，叫他去救他的同伴。
When they tired of their fun and left the scene, Roger crawled up the riverbank and onto a nearby road. He was rescued at 11pm by a passing motorist who took him to a hospital. It was Bevan Spencer Von Einem. On July 28, 1983, detectives Trevor Kipling and Bob O'Brien drove to Von Einem's home in Paradise, a suburb 11km northeast of Adelaide that he shared with his mother. The ordinary beige brick low set was tidy with a freshly mowed lawn and sparse shrubs dotting the front yard. Von Einem, a tall man with dark brown hair, dark eyes and a large bulbous nose, answered the door. The detectives asked him to accompany them to the police station so they could question him about his use of mandrakes. Von Einem said he wouldn't talk unless he had his solicitor present.
当他们玩够了并离开现场后，罗杰爬上河岸，来到附近的一条路上。晚上11点，他被一名路过的驾车者救起并送往医院。这个人就是贝文·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆。1983年7月28日，侦探特雷弗·基普林和鲍勃·奥布赖恩驱车前往冯·艾内姆位于天堂镇的住所。这是一个位于阿德莱德东北11公里处的郊区，他和母亲住在这里。这栋普通的米色砖墙平房很整洁，草坪修剪得整整齐齐，前院点缀着稀疏的灌木。冯·艾内姆个子高挑，留着深棕色头发，有着黑色的眼睛和一个硕大的酒糟鼻，他来开的门。侦探要求他陪同前往警察局，以便就他使用曼德拉草一事对他进行讯问。冯·艾内姆说，除非有律师在场，否则他不会说话。
Later that day he arrived at the Angus Street police building with his solicitor. He admitted to taking a number of medications to help with his nervous condition and insomnia, listing seropax, sinequan and rehypnole. When asked about mandrakes, Von Einem replied that he had started taking it about five years prior. He said the last time he would have filled a prescription for mandrakes would have been a year ago. He still had a few tablets left, but he now took rehypnole to get to sleep instead. Von Einem denied any knowledge of what happened to Alan Barnes, Neil Muir, Mark Langley, Peter Stognef or Richard Kelvin. As detailed in the book Young Blood by Detective Bob O'Brien, when asked if it was conceivable that he could abduct a youth, drug him, abuse him and then kill him, Von Einem replied, No, I think it would be unethical of me. I shy away from violence of any description.
当天晚些时候，他在律师的陪同下来到安古斯街警察局。他承认自己服用了多种药物来治疗神经系统疾病和失眠症，并列举了安定（seropax）、多虑平（sinequan）和氟硝西泮（rehypnole）。当被问及曼德拉草时，冯·艾内姆回答说，他大约在五年前开始服用。他说，他上一次开具曼德拉草处方大概是一年前。他手里还剩几片药，但他现在改服氟硝西泮来助眠。冯·艾内姆否认自己知道艾伦·巴恩斯、尼尔·穆尔、马克·兰利、彼得·斯托涅夫或理查德·凯尔文身上发生了什么。正如侦探鲍勃·奥布赖恩在《年轻的血》一书中所详述的那样，当被问及他是否有可能绑架一名青少年、给他下药、虐待他然后杀害他时，冯·艾内姆回答说：“不，我认为这样做是不道德的。我对任何形式的暴力都避之唯恐不及。”
Detective O'Brien thought to himself that these were not words a normal person would use. Bevan Von Einem consented to supplying blood and hair samples as well as providing fingernail scrapings. He also let detectives search his silver Toyota Corona hatchback and his home. At 4.15pm, detectives Kipling and O'Brien, along with a crime scene examiner, photographer and fingerprint analyst, entered Von Einem's home while he waited outside. The interior of the house was nothing remarkable at first glance, with plain furniture decorating the lounge. The group moved across the vibrant blue and purple swelled carpet and into Von Einem's bedroom near the front of the house. At the foot of Von Einem's bed sat a harp, visible over his bright orange and yellow checkered bedspread. Next to the bed was a carry bag.
奥布赖恩侦探心想，这些绝对不是一个正常人会说的话。贝文·冯·艾内姆同意提供血液和头发样本以及指甲刮片。他还允许侦探搜查他的银色丰田花冠两厢车和他的家。下午4点15分，基普林和奥布赖恩侦探以及犯罪现场勘查员、摄影师和指纹分析师进入了冯·艾内姆的家中，而他则在外面等候。乍一看，房子的内部并没有什么特别之处，客厅里装饰着简朴的家具。一行人穿过色彩鲜艳的蓝紫色膨胀地毯，来到了位于房屋前部附近的冯·艾内姆的卧室。在冯·艾内姆的床脚放着一把竖琴，透过他那明亮的橙黄色相间床单清晰可见。床旁边放着一个手提包。
It contained a bottle of Cinequan, Cerepax, Rehypnol and Valium tablets. A note inside read, Uncle Bevan. Detective O'Brien asked Von Einem where his mandrakes could be found. He directed them to a cupboard in his bedroom and pulled out two bottles concealed behind a mirror. Von Einem said that there would be about 40 tablets in the bottles. When asked if there was anything else hidden in his bedroom, Von Einem said no. Checking the ledge behind the mirror, Detective O'Brien withdrew another bottle. It was labelled as Noctek, its active ingredient being Chlorohydrate.
里面有一瓶多虑平（Cinequan）、安定（Cerepax）、氟硝西泮（Rehypnol）和安定（Valium）药片。里面的一张便条写着：贝文叔叔。奥布赖恩侦探问冯·艾内姆他的曼德拉草放在哪里。他把他们带到卧室里的一个橱柜前，拉出了藏在一面镜子后面的两个瓶子。冯·艾内姆说瓶子里大概有40片药。当被问及卧室里是否还藏有其他东西时，冯·艾内姆回答说没有。奥布赖恩侦探检查了镜子后面的壁架，又拿出了另一个瓶子。上面贴着诺曲（Noctek）的标签，其活性成分是水合氯醛。
After fingerprinting, photographs and tape lifts of Von Einem's car and house had been completed, the detectives returned to the police station to complete their paperwork. They finished up around 10pm. As detailed in the book Youngblood, Detective O'Brien, too wired from the day's events to sleep, decided to do a drive-by of Von Einem's house. He saw an unfamiliar car parked in the driveway and the lounge room light was on. O'Brien parked a distance away and waited. By 1.30 the next morning, the owner of the vehicle had still not left the premises.
在对冯·艾内姆的汽车和住所完成指纹提取、拍照以及胶带提取物取样后，侦探们返回警察局做文书工作。他们在晚上10点左右结束。正如书籍《年轻之血》中所详细描述的那样，侦探奥布莱恩因为白天的经历而精神亢奋无法入睡，决定开车去冯·艾内姆的住所外巡视一番。他看到车道上停着一辆陌生轿车，休息室的灯还亮着。奥布莱恩将车停在远处等待。直到次日凌晨1点30分，该车辆的车主仍未离开。
The weary detective called it a night. Later that morning, a plate check for the vehicle parked in Von Einem's driveway came back as a match for an affluent businessman who worked in the Adelaide CBD. With not enough evidence to arrest Bevan Von Einem, on September 19, detectives organised a raid on the man who had visited him on the night his house was searched, the affluent businessman. His name is still under a suppression order. For the sake of clarity, case file will refer to him as Mr Rar.
疲惫的侦探决定结束这一晚。那天晚些时候，对停在冯·艾内姆车道上的车辆进行的车牌查询结果显示，车主是一名在阿德莱德中央商务区工作的富商。由于没有足够证据逮捕贝万·冯·艾内姆，9月19日，侦探们对在其住所被搜查当晚拜访过他的一位富商展开了突击搜查。此人的姓名仍处于禁止报道令之下。为了表述清晰，案卷将称他为Rar先生。
His name had been mentioned amongst the hundreds called in to the major crime squad tip line during the family murders investigation, but he hadn't raised serious red flags until he was linked as an associate of Bevan Spencer Von Einem. Mr Rar was at his home in one of Adelaide's most affluent suburbs when officers arrived to carry out their raid. Mr Rar admitted to knowing Von Einem for years, considering him a friend. He denied any knowledge of the family murders and refused to comment any further. His home was searched, but nothing incriminating was found. Following this, the detectives also searched Mr Rar's business,
在家庭谋杀案调查期间，向重案组热线打进电话的数百人中曾提到过他的名字，但在他被发现与贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆有交往之前，他并未引起警方的高度警惕。当警员们抵达进行突击搜查时，Rar先生正位于阿德莱德最富裕的郊区之一的家中。Rar先生承认认识冯·艾内姆多年，视其为朋友。他否认自己对家庭谋杀案有任何了解，并拒绝进一步发表评论。他的家被搜查了，但没有发现任何 incriminating（能够定罪的）证据。在此之后，侦探们还搜查了Rar先生的企业，
a two-story building located in a busy shopping district of Adelaide. Upstairs, towards the rear of the building, detectives O'Brien and Kipling came across a room devoid of any furniture or decoration, except for a bare mattress on the ground. The mattress was seized, but there was no evidence to show that any of the murdered young men had been anywhere near it. Despite this, authorities remained suspicious of Mr Rar and placed him under lengthy surveillance. While he never did anything illegal, he did have a specific routine. As detailed in the book Youngblood,
这是一栋两层建筑，位于阿德莱德繁华的购物区。在二楼建筑后方，侦探奥布莱恩和基普林偶然发现了一个房间，里面没有任何家具或装饰，只有地上放着一个光秃秃的床垫。床垫被查获了，但没有证据表明任何被谋杀的年轻男子曾靠近过它。尽管如此，当局对Rar先生仍然保持怀疑，并对他进行了长时间的监视。虽然他从未做过违法的事，但他确实有特定的日常规律。正如书籍《年轻之血》中所详细描述的那样，
every weekday Mr Rar would close his business at precisely 12 o'clock for one hour. He would then drive to the number one beat to see what was happening there before checking out other beats. At the end of his lunch break, he would return to work. Although he lived very close to his business premises, the trip would be repeated at the end of the day after he closed. Each time, he was looking for young men to pick up. In November, a call was placed to the Major Crime Squad's office. The caller, who remained anonymous, would come to be known as Mr B. He had phoned the police during the early investigations into the murders of Alan Barnes and Neil Muir as he had a friend who knew them both.
每个工作日中午整整12点，Rar先生都会准时关门一个小时。然后他会开车去“一号同性恋聚集地”（beat）看看那里发生了什么，再去检查其他聚集地。午休结束时，他会返回工作岗位。尽管他住得离营业场所非常近，但在关门下班后，他会重复这一行程。每一次，他都在寻找可以搭讪的年轻男子。11月，重案组办公室接到了一个电话。打电话的人保持匿名，后来被称为B先生。在早期调查阿伦·巴恩斯和尼尔·缪尔谋杀案时他就报过警，因为他有一个朋友同时认识这两人。
However, because detectives were eyeing Dr Peter Milhouse as the likely perpetrator, they focused all their attention on him. Now, Mr B had more to share than just a name. He was ready to discuss in detail, Bevan Spencer von Einem. In a six-hour interview, Mr B detailed how he met and befriended von Einem at the number one beat weeks before the death of Alan Barnes. Mr B detailed how he and von Einem would pick up hitchhikers and supply them with alcohol that von Einem kept in an eski in his car. Once the men were inebriated, the pair would offer them pills, saying they would help sober them up. In reality, the pills were sedatives. From the book Youngblood, Mr B detailed the aftermath of one such setup.
然而，由于侦探们将彼得·米尔ハウス（Peter Milhouse）医生视为可能的嫌疑人，他们将全部注意力都集中在了他身上。现在，B先生要分享的不仅仅是一个名字。他准备详细谈论贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆。在长达六小时的访谈中，B先生详细讲述了他在阿伦·巴恩斯死前几周，如何在“一号聚集地”结识并与冯·艾内姆成为朋友的。B先生详细描述了他和冯·艾内姆如何搭载搭便车的人，并向他们提供冯·艾内姆放在车内冰桶里的酒精饮料。一旦这些人喝醉了，两人就会向他们提供药丸，谎称这能帮他们醒酒。实际上，这些药丸是镇静剂。根据《年轻之血》一书，B先生详细描述了这样一场阴谋之后的善后工作。
Bevan took the kid by the arms and I had the legs and we carried him into the bedroom, which was Bevan's, and we put him straight onto the bed with his head on the pillow. We brought the second one in the same way and dropped him on the lounge room floor. Bevan then went into his bedroom and closed the door. I did not touch the one in the lounge room. I would have, but he was not good looking and he was rolling around as though he was going to be sick. Mr B then walked into von Einem's room and saw him performing horrific acts on the young man. Mr B asked von Einem to take him home and the two of them dropped the drugged boys to the albedon house of Miss P and her friends, where they slept off the effects and went home. On November 3, Bevan Spencer von Einem went out to get groceries with his mother.
贝万抓住那个孩子的胳膊，我抓着他的腿，我们把他抬进卧室，那是贝万的房间，我们把他直接放在床上，头枕在枕头上。我们以同样的方式把第二个孩子抬进来，扔在客厅的地板上。然后贝万走进他的卧室关上了门。我没有碰客厅里的那个。我本来想碰的，但他长得不好看，而且翻来滚去，好像要吐的样子。接着B先生走进冯·艾内姆的房间，看到他对那个年轻人进行可怕的虐待。B先生要求冯·艾内姆送他回家，两人将下药的男孩们送到P小姐及其朋友们的阿莱顿住宅，他们在那里睡过药效后各自回家。11月3日，贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆和他的母亲出门买杂货。
Afterwards, as he pulled into the driveway of his home, he was arrested by Detective Trevor Kipling for the murder of Richard Kelvin. Analysis of the brightly coloured fibres recovered on the clothing worn by Richard Kelvin had come back as a perfect match to those on the carpet and bedspread in the von Einem home. 110 fibres were a match to von Einem's brown cardigan. This evidence, combined with a signed statement by Mr B and mandrakes and chloral hydrate found in von Einem's bedroom, was enough to warrant an arrest. Von Einem's mother was shocked and couldn't believe what was happening. Her son showed no emotion at all. Von Einem adamantly denied knowing what happened to Richard Kelvin. He was held on remand and at his committal hearing in February the following year, von Einem's attorney halted proceedings to read out a statement on behalf of his client. It claimed that von Einem did meet Richard Kelvin on the night he was abducted, however, he was not involved with his disappearance or murder.
之后，当他把车开进自家车道时，侦探特雷弗·基普林因理查德·凯尔文的谋杀案将他逮捕。在理查德·凯尔文穿的衣服上提取到的颜色鲜艳的纤维经分析，与冯·艾内姆家中的地毯和床罩上的纤维完全吻合。有110根纤维与冯·艾内姆的棕色开衫相配。这一证据，加上B先生签署的证词，以及在冯·艾内姆卧室里发现的曼陀罗和水合氯醛，足以构成逮捕令。冯·艾内姆的母亲大受震撼，无法相信发生的一切。她的儿子却表现得毫无情绪。冯·艾内姆坚决否认自己知道理查德·凯尔文身上发生了什么。他被还押候审，并在次年2月的预审听证会上，冯·艾内姆的律师暂停了诉讼程序，宣读了一份代表其当事人的声明。声明称，冯·艾内姆确实在理查德被绑架的那天晚上见过他，但他没有参与理查德的失踪或谋杀。
The hearing was postponed while detectives investigated these new claims. On March 1, von Einem was re-interviewed. This time, he claimed that on the afternoon of Richard's disappearance he was driving to get fish and chips for dinner when he almost struck Richard with his car. He spoke briefly to Richard, who noticed that von Einem was drinking a beer and asked if he could have one as well. Not wanting Richard to get in trouble for underage drinking, von Einem said that Richard got into his car and the two had a drink while driving back to his home in Paradise. Richard told von Einem of his troubles at school with bullying, a fact that had been printed in the papers following his disappearance. To help calm him, von Einem said Richard sat on his bed while he played the harp for him and put his arm around him in a comforting gesture. After two hours of von Einem consoling the distraught teen, he said that he drove Richard back into town opposite the Royal Adelaide Hospital. Instead of dropping him at his home, von Einem said that he gave him $20 to catch a taxi parked outside of the hospital.
听证会被推迟，以便侦探们调查这些新说法。3月1日，冯·艾内姆再次接受讯问。这一次，他声称在理查德失踪那天下午，他开车去买炸鱼薯条当晚餐时，差点用车撞到理查德。他与理查德简短交谈，理查德注意到冯·艾内姆在喝啤酒，便问自己是否也能喝一杯。为了不让理查德因未成年饮酒而惹麻烦，冯·艾内姆说理查德上了他的车，两人在开车回天堂区住所的路上喝了一杯。理查德向冯·艾内姆倾诉了他在学校遭受霸凌的烦恼，这一事实在他失踪后曾被报纸报道过。为了帮他平静下来，冯·艾内姆说理查德坐在他的床上，而他为理查德弹奏竖琴，并搂住他的肩膀以示安慰。在冯·艾内姆安慰这位情绪崩溃的少年两个小时后，他说自己开车把理查德送回了城里，就在皇家阿德莱德医院对面。冯·艾内姆说，他没有把理查德送到家，而是给了他20美元去坐停在医院外面的出租车。
Despite these assertions, von Einem was ordered to stand trial for the murder of Richard Kelvin. Media descended on the South Australian Supreme Court as Bevan Spencer von Einem was brought in for the first day of his trial on October 15, 1984. A seven woman and five male jury listened, as prosecutors pointed to all the evidence linking von Einem to the abduction and murder of Richard Kelvin. Aside from the fiber evidence and medications found in Richard's system, there was other incriminating evidence. The day after Richard Kelvin disappeared, von Einem had his hair coloured by a hairdressing friend of his. From the age of 16, he had gone prematurely grey and had his hair dyed dark brown every month. Von Einem did not dispute this claim, telling the jury that although he was sick with the flu, Monday, June 6, 1983, was the only day that his hairdresser was free to do his hair. The alibi worked against von Einem when the seven hairs found on the inside of Richard's jeans exactly matched the hair dye used to colour his hair.
尽管有这些辩解，冯·艾内姆仍被命令为谋杀理查德·凯尔文接受审判。1984年10月15日，当贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆被带进审判第一天时，媒体蜂拥至南澳大利亚最高法院。由七名女性和五名男性组成的陪审团认真聆听，检察官们指出了将冯·艾内姆与理查德·凯尔文的绑架和谋杀联系起来的所有证据。除了纤维证据和理查德体内发现的药物外，还有其他 incriminating（定罪）证据。在理查德·凯尔文失踪的第二天，冯·艾内姆让他的美发师朋友帮他染了头发。从16岁起，他就过早地白了头，每个月都要把头发染成深褐色。冯·艾内姆对这一说法没有异议，他向陪审团表示，尽管他得了流感，但1983年6月6日星期一是他美发师唯一有空给他做头发的日子。当在理查德牛仔裤内侧发现的七根头发与用于给他染发的人工染料完全吻合时，这个不在场证明反而对冯·艾内姆不利。
They also had a small amount of grey regrowth. In the week after Richard was abducted, von Einem took the week off work, telling his employer that he had the flu. Six days after Richard's body was dumped, von Einem sold his car, but not before giving the interior of the boot a new paint job. Von Einem claimed he did this to remove rust caused by a leaking ascii, but detectives were certain he covered up bloodstaining or other evidence. In a 12-page unsworn statement in his defence, von Einem asked the jury to accept the version of events regarding his meeting with Richard Kelvin and to find him not guilty. On November 5, the jury retired to consider a verdict. Seven and a half hours later, they returned to announce Bevan Spencer von Einem guilty. The public gallery erupted into cheers and applause, an act almost unheard of in the 1980s and visibly surprising Justice Michael White.
他们还发现了一小段灰白色的新发根。在理查德被绑架后的那一周里，冯尼姆请了一周假，告诉雇主他得了流感。在理查德的尸体被抛弃六天后，冯尼姆卖掉了他的车，但在卖车之前，他给后备箱内部重新喷了漆。冯尼姆声称他这样做是为了清除由泄漏的冷冻剂引起的铁锈，但侦探们确信他是为了掩盖血迹或其他证据。在一份长达12页的未宣誓辩护声明中，冯尼姆要求陪审团接受他关于与理查德·凯尔文会面的事件版本，并判定他无罪。11月5日，陪审团退庭商议裁决。七个半小时后，他们返回宣布贝万·斯宾塞·冯尼姆有罪。公众旁听席爆发出一片欢呼和掌声，这在20世纪80年代几乎闻所未闻，也让迈克尔·怀特法官感到明显惊讶。
Bevan von Einem sat passively, showing no emotion at the outcome. Before sentencing, Justice White said the following. The horrendous nature of this crime involving, as it did, a long period of imprisonment and ill treatment prior to murder has added a new dimension to the kinds of murder committed in the state with which the community has to live. You do not show remorse, you do not admit guilt. You showed yourself to be cool and violent at the time of abduction, inventive and resourceful during imprisonment of the youth. Ready to resort to lies and false alibis after the discovery of the body and you are unrepentant at the moment. Bevan Spencer von Einem was sentenced to life imprisonment with a non-parole period of 24 years. His sentence was immediately appealed by the South Australian Attorney General and in March 1985, von Einem's non-parole period was increased to 36 years, the highest sentence ever imposed on a person in South Australia.
贝万·冯·艾内姆无动于衷地坐着，对结果毫无情绪表现。在宣判前，怀特法官发表了以下言论。这起犯罪的恐怖性质——正如它所包含的那样，在谋杀前经历了长时间的监禁和虐待——为该州发生的各类谋杀案增添了一个新的维度，这是社会必须与之共存的。你没有表现出悔意，你没有承认罪行。你在绑架时表现得冷酷而暴力，在囚禁青年期间富有发明创造和机智。在尸体被发现后诉诸谎言和虚假的不在场证明，此时此刻你毫无悔意。贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆被判处终身监禁，不得假释期为24年。南澳大利亚州总检察长立即对他的刑期提起上诉，1985年3月，冯·艾内姆的不得假释期被延长至36年，这是南澳大利亚历史上对个人实施的最高刑罚。
In explaining his decision, Chief Justice Michael King said, The present crime indicates such a depravity of character on the part of the perpetrator that his absence of previous convictions loses its significance. The abduction, captivity, sedation, abuse and murder of the boy did not occur on impulse and could only have been perpetrated by a person or persons of grossly depraved character. In early 1988, an inquest was opened into the deaths of Alan Barnes, Neil Muir, Peter Stognef and Mark Langley after earlier individual inquests determined that there was enough evidence linking these murders together. It was believed now more than ever that Bevan Spencer von Einem was involved in these crimes and he did not carry them out alone. Yet, there was only enough evidence to charge and convict him of the one murder. Even from a prison cell, von Einem refused to name any of his associates. Alan's mother Judy Barnes was grateful for the inquest, telling Paper the news that South Australia would be rocked to its little grassroots if the names of the murderers were released. The killers are not hoons, not down the street deviance. They are professional people.
首席大法官迈克尔·金在解释他的判决时说，目前的犯罪表明肇事者具有如此堕落的性格，以至于他没有前科这一点也失去了意义。对男孩的绑架、囚禁、下药、虐待和谋杀并非一时冲动，只能由一个或多个性格极其堕落的人实施。1988年初，在早先的独立死因研讯确定有足够证据将这些谋杀案联系在一起之后，对阿伦·巴恩斯、尼尔·缪尔、彼得·斯托涅夫和马克·兰利死因的研讯正式开启。现在人们比以往任何时候都更确信贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆参与了这些罪行，而且他并非独自作案。然而，现有的证据只够指控并定罪他谋杀其中一人。即使在狱中，冯·艾内姆也拒绝说出任何同伙的名字。阿伦的母亲朱迪·巴恩斯对这次研讯表示感激，她告诉报社，如果公开谋杀者的名字，南澳大利亚将会发生天翻地覆的变化。杀手不是小混混，也不是街头异类。他们是专业人士。
At the inquest, Detective Trevor Kipling spoke of a special unit set up by the major crime squad to investigate incidents where young men had been lured into passing cars and then drugged and anally assaulted. Like George, other victims came forward to say they had been picked up and given drinks that were laced with drugs. They spoke of passing out and waking up at a stranger's house where there lived transgender women before being allowed to be let go. Members of the gay community cooperated fully with the detectives as they patrolled known beats, appalled by the killings. In presenting the findings, the coroner stated, I have perused a number of statements from victims who survived the ordeal. Statements by these people have been checked and rechecked and there is no doubt that their account of what happened is substantially true and certainly not fanciful. In early September 1988, spurred by public interest in naming other members of the family, the South Australian government offered half a million dollars and immunity from prosecution for any information leading to the conviction of anyone involved in the murders. They hoped an increase in the reward, which had previously been set at 100,000 and then a quarter of a million dollars, would be what was needed to convict the other killers.
在研讯中，侦探特雷弗·基普林谈到了重案组成立的一个特别小队，旨在调查年轻男子被诱骗上过路汽车随后被下药和鸡奸的事件。像乔治一样，其他受害者也站出来说他们被载走，并被灌了掺药的饮料。他们讲述了自己失去知觉并在一个陌生人的家里醒来的经历，那里住着跨性别女性，之后他们才被允许离开。同性恋社区的成员全力配合侦探们在已知的聚集地巡逻，他们对这些杀戮感到震惊。首席验尸官在陈述调查结果时表示，我仔细阅读了多份幸存过这场折磨的受害者的证词。这些人的证词经过了一再核实，毫无疑问，他们对所发生事情的叙述大体上是真实的，绝非异想天开。1988年9月初，在公众对查明该家族其他成员身份的热情推动下，南澳大利亚政府悬赏50万美元，并对提供任何有助于将任何涉案人员定罪的信息的人提供免于起诉的保护。他们希望提高悬赏金额——此前悬赏金已定为10万美元，后来提高到25万美元——能够成为将其他凶手定罪所需的关键。
In September 1989, Mr. B told detectives that he had more information to give about Von Einem. In order to get the information, Mr. B was offered immunity from prosecution if it was established that he was responsible for any sexual abuse towards the victims involved. Mr. B detailed meeting up with Von Einem the night Alan Barnes went missing. He recalled how they had picked up the hitchhiker, who asked if he could get a lift to his family home in Salisbury. Von Einem offered Alan a drink. As they drove along, Mr. B said he asked Alan if he wanted to go to a party and Alan replied that he did. Some time later, Von Einem exited the vehicle to make a phone call. He told Mr. B that he had arranged to meet an associate of his at a toilet block on the River Torrens near Jolly's Boat House.
1989年9月，B先生告诉侦探他有更多关于冯·艾内姆的信息要提供。为了获取这些信息，如果查明B先生对所涉及的受害者负有任何性虐待责任，将向其提供免于起诉的豁免权。B先生详细描述了在阿伦·巴恩斯失踪当晚与冯·艾内姆会面的情景。他回忆了他们如何搭载这名搭便车的人，这名搭便车的人要求搭车去他在索尔兹伯里的家。冯·艾内姆给阿伦递了一杯饮料。当他们驱车前行时，B先生说他问阿伦是否想去参加一个派对，阿伦回答说想去。过了一会儿，冯·艾内姆下车去打电话。他告诉B先生，他已经安排在乔利船屋附近的托伦斯河边的一个厕所旁与他的一个同伙会面。
They drove to the location and Mr. B sat in the car while Von Einem went to speak to his friend. Alan Barnes was unconscious on the rear seat of the vehicle. A short while later, Von Einem returned and asked Mr. B, Do you want to come with us and do some surgery on this guy, indicating in Alan Barnes's direction? According to Mr. B, Von Einem said that it would be worth his while to come along, because they were planning to sexually assault him with various instruments and video it, before killing him and dumping his body in the Adelaide Hills. Mr. B said he declined and walked off.
他们开车前往该地点，B先生坐在车里，而冯·艾内姆则去和他的朋友说话。阿伦·巴恩斯当时昏迷在汽车后座上。过了一会儿，冯·艾内姆回来问B先生：“你想跟我们一起来对这家伙做点手术吗？”并指向阿伦·巴恩斯的方向。据B先生称，冯·艾内姆说跟他一起来是值得的，因为他们计划用各种器械对阿伦进行性侵并录像，然后杀害他并将尸体抛在阿德莱德山。B先生说他拒绝了并走开了。
A few days later, Mr. B met Von Einem in the city. Von Einem told Mr. B that Alan had died and that if he said anything, he would be implicated in the murder. With this new evidence, on September 15, Von Einem was charged with the murder of Alan Barnes. Given the similarities in the manner of death between Alan and Mark Langley, on November 10, he was charged for his murder as well. At the committal hearing, a friend of Alan's named Gary gave evidence that he had been introduced to Von Einem and some of his friends the week before he disappeared. Von Einem told them both that if he and Alan provided sexual favours, they could get drugs, women, or anything they wanted.
几天后，B先生在城里遇到了冯·艾内姆。冯·艾内姆告诉B先生，阿伦已经死了，如果他说出任何事，他将被牵连进这起谋杀案。凭借这一新证据，9月15日，冯·艾内姆被控谋杀阿伦·巴恩斯。鉴于阿伦和马克·兰利的死因有相似之处，11月10日，他也被指控谋杀马克·兰利。在预审听证会上，阿伦的一位名叫加里的朋友作证说，在阿伦失踪前一周，他被介绍认识了冯·艾内姆和他的几个朋友。冯·艾内姆告诉他们俩，如果他和阿伦提供性服务，他们就能得到毒品、女人或任何他们想要的东西。
This offer also stood if they provided Von Einem with young boys. Gary had failed to come forward with this information prior because of the 200 threatening phone calls he had received, starting on the night Alan's body was found and continuing until the committal hearing. The most recent one was a phone call made to his work. The muffled voice said, keep your mouth shut or you and your wife will get it. In an explosive day of allegations, Mr. B gave evidence that Von Einem had confessed to him murdering the Beaumont children in 1966 as well as Joanne Ratcliffe and Kirsty Gordon in 1973.
如果他们向冯·艾内姆提供小男孩，这个条件同样成立。加里之前没有透露这些信息，是因为他收到了200个威胁电话，从阿伦尸体被发现的那天晚上开始，一直持续到预审听证会。最近的一次是打到他工作单位的电话。那个低沉的声音说：“管好你的嘴，否则你和你的妻子都会遭殃。”在充满爆炸性指控的一天里，B先生作证说，冯·艾内姆曾向他坦白，他谋杀了1966年的博蒙特三姐弟以及1973年的乔安妮·拉特克利夫和柯斯蒂·戈登。
These crimes are covered in episodes 100 and 163 of case file respectively. Von Einem couldn't be directly linked to either crime. Mr. B told the court, I have given consideration to the relatives of these kids. They deserve to know what really happened. When asked during cross-examination whether the reward money for these disappearances played any part in him coming forward with these allegations, Mr. B said it did, but only because he felt he needed to flee the country during Beaumont's life. Adding to his fear, he said, It was that one of the people he thought may have been involved in the killing of Alan Barnes was sitting in the public gallery while he gave evidence.
这些罪行分别在《案件档案》第100集和第163集中有所涉及。冯·艾内姆无法直接与这两起罪行联系起来。B先生对法庭表示：“我考虑过这些孩子的亲属。他们理应知道真相。”在接受盘问时，当被问及这些失踪案的悬赏金是否促使他站出来指控时，B先生表示确实如此，但那只是因为他觉得自己在博蒙特生前必须逃离国外。他增加了内心的恐惧，他说：“在他作证时，他认为可能参与谋杀艾伦·巴恩斯的人之一正坐在旁听席上。”
Bevan Von Einem was ordered to stand trial for the murders of Alan Barnes and Mark Langley. In December 1990, the trial judge decided to allow the evidence of Mr. B in the committal hearing regarding Alan Barnes for the upcoming trial. For the Mark Langley case, the prosecution was relying on using similar fact evidence. They were going to argue that the abduction and murder of Mark Langley was so similar to that of Richard Kelvin that it meant Von Einem should be found guilty. However, Von Einem's counsel successfully argued that comparing Mark's death against Richard Kelvin would suggest criminal liability. Just before Christmas Day 1990, the prosecution received instructions from the South Australian Attorney General not to proceed with the case of Mark Langley and the charges against Von Einem were dropped. In February 1991, Von Einem appeared in the Supreme Court for a total of 30 seconds. The prosecution said that they had been instructed by the South Australian Attorney General to not pursue charges against Von Einem regarding the murder of Alan Barnes, either.
贝万·冯·艾内姆被下令就谋杀艾伦·巴恩斯和马克·兰格利一案接受审判。1990年12月，审判法官决定在即将到来的审判中，允许在关于艾伦·巴恩斯的听证会上采纳B先生的证词。对于马克·兰格利案，控方依靠的是相似事实证据。他们打算辩称，马克·兰格利的绑架和谋杀与理查德·凯尔文的案件非常相似，这意味着冯·艾内姆应该被判有罪。然而，冯·艾内姆的辩护律师成功地辩称，将马克的死与理查德·凯尔文进行比较会暗示刑事责任。就在1990年圣诞节前夕，控方接到南澳大利亚州总检察长的指示，不再对马克·兰格利案进行诉讼，针对冯·艾内姆的指控被撤销。1991年2月，冯·艾内姆在最高法院出庭，总共只持续了30秒。控方表示，他们已接到南澳大利亚州总检察长的指示，同样不再追究冯·艾内姆谋杀艾伦·巴恩斯的罪名。
The Attorney General had received legal advice that there was no reasonable prospect of a conviction on the available admissible evidence. Over the course of Bevan Spencer Von Einem's incarceration, snippets regarding the life of privilege he led came to light. In 2006, a former prison officer known as Mary detailed to the Sunday Mail the close friendship she had formed with Von Einem over the years. Describing the convicted killer as polite, friendly and gentle, Mary did not see him as the monster that others did. She supplied Von Einem with home-cooked meals, including bacon and eggs on Sunday morning and his favorite, pey and ham soup. She also purchased art supplies for him when Von Einem mentioned that he wanted to do some painting. Other prison officers paid for painted Von Einem greeting cards, either with cash or tobacco. He also used an officer's mobile phone from time to time.
总检察长收到了法律意见，认为根据现有的可采纳证据，没有合理的定罪希望。在贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆服刑期间，有关他过的特权生活的一些碎片逐渐浮出水面。2006年，一名被称为玛丽的前狱警向《星期日邮报》详细讲述了她多年来与冯·艾内姆建立的亲密友谊。玛丽将这名被定罪的杀人犯描述为礼貌、友好和温和，并没有像其他人那样把他视为怪物。她为冯·艾内姆提供家常饭菜，包括周日早上的培根鸡蛋以及他最喜欢的豌豆火腿汤。当冯·艾内姆提到他想画画时，她还为他购买了美术用品。其他狱警用现金或烟草购买了冯·艾内姆画的贺卡。他有时还会使用警官的手机。
Mary admitted to letting Von Einem sit in the officer's station, which contained confidential prisoner information while they enjoyed cake and a cup of coffee together. Other officers turned a blind eye to it. Mary said that Von Einem spent most of his prison time drawing, painting, reading and watching soap operas and reality TV. According to the advertiser, in 2005, Bevan Spencer Von Einem was prescribed the drug Cialis by a prison doctor. Similar to Viagra, Cialis is used to treat erectile dysfunction, however, is longer lasting. In mid-2005, under the influence of the medication, Von Einem raped and assaulted a fellow prisoner to the point where he needed extensive surgery to repair internal injuries. In early May 2007, a subsequent rape charge against Von Einem was dropped after the director of public prosecutions decided there was insufficient evidence to secure a conviction. Bitterly disappointed, the victim's mother stated that her son's silence was interpreted to have been consent when in fact Von Einem had repeatedly coerced, drugged and threatened him.
玛丽承认让冯·艾内姆坐在警官的值班室里，里面有机密的囚犯信息，同时他们一起享用蛋糕和一杯咖啡。其他警官对此视而不见。玛丽说，冯·艾内姆大部分的监狱时间都在画画、阅读、看肥皂剧和真人秀。据《广告人报》报道，2005年，贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆被监狱医生开具了西地那非（西力士）药物。与伟哥类似，西力士用于治疗勃起功能障碍，但药效更持久。2005年中期，在药物的影响下，冯·艾内姆强奸并袭击了一名同狱犯人，导致该犯人需要进行广泛的手术来修复体内损伤。2007年5月初，在公共检察署认为没有足够证据定罪后，针对冯·艾内姆的后续强奸指控被撤销。受害者母亲感到极其失望，她表示她儿子的沉默被解释为了同意，而实际上冯·艾内姆曾多次对其实施强迫、下药和威胁。
Following this, the drug Cialis and similar medications were banned from prisons. In February 2014, Trevor Peter's brother was cleaning out his deceased siblings' terrace house in Kensington Park. As reported in the advertiser, he came across a diary belonging to Trevor and thumbed through it. He reached an entry in late June of 1979, just after Alan Barnes went missing. It described how Trevor was getting his hair coloured at his friend's salon. The same salon that Bevan Spencer Von Einem visited to get his hair coloured the day after Richard Kelvin disappeared. While Trevor was waiting for the bleach to dye his hair, he said that Bevan Spencer Von Einem walked in. The diary entry read,
在此之后，西力士药物和类似药物在监狱中被禁。2014年2月，特雷弗·彼得斯的弟弟正在肯辛顿公园清理他已故兄弟的联排别墅。正如《广告人报》报道的那样，他偶然发现了一本属于特雷弗的日记并翻阅了它。他翻到了1979年6月下旬的一篇日记，就在艾伦·巴恩斯失踪后不久。日记中描述了特雷弗如何在朋友的沙龙里染头发。就是贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆在理查德·凯尔文失踪后第二天去染头发的那家沙龙。特雷弗在等待漂白剂染发时，说贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆走了进来。日记写道：
He was in a very happy mood and looking knowingly at the hairdresser, smiling broadly and excited about something they both seemed to share. I could hear Bevan and the hairdresser giggling and laughing and both saying, Ooh, how evil. Ooh, it's evil. I found them huddled over a waist-high table directly behind the curtain of the salon. There was a group of photographs, polaroids, laid out on the table, maybe four, five or six of them, with Bevan holding more photographs in his hand. They both began to collect the photos quickly, but not before I saw them. The photographs were of a young attractive blonde-haired man lying on his side on the front seat of a car with his legs bent towards the steering wheel. I was shocked at seeing the photos and they both hurriedly gathered them up with Bevan putting them all into his back pocket of his trousers.
他当时心情非常好，意味深长地看着美发师，咧嘴大笑，为他们俩似乎心照不宣的事情感到兴奋。我能听到贝万和美发师在咯咯笑着，两人都在说：“哦，多邪恶啊。哦，太邪恶了。”我发现他们挤在沙龙窗帘后面一张齐腰高的桌子旁。桌上摆着一组宝丽来照片，大概有四、五张或六张，贝万手里还拿着更多的照片。他们俩开始迅速收集照片，但还没等我看到。照片是一个年轻迷人的金发男子侧身躺在汽车前座上，双腿朝向方向盘。看到这些照片我感到很震惊，他们俩匆忙地把照片收起来，贝万把它们全塞进了裤子后袋里。
When I asked who the young man was, Bevan said, Oh, just some hitchhiker. The collection of photos as described by Trevor Peters was so graphic that their description has not been publicly released. According to the advertiser, in the 1990s, Trevor Peters wrote in his diary that he visited the hairdresser at Calvary Hospital to confront him about the photographs he had seen at his salon that day over a decade earlier. They sat together in the hospital garden and the hairdresser told Trevor of the many photographs he had been shown by Von Einem. There were dozens of naked young men, more often than not with objects, including bottles inserted deep into their anuses. Trevor wrote in his diary, However, he said, smiling at me, he didn't remember there being any photos at the salon ever, and if you know what's good for you, neither should you. He died four days later. Despite numerous appeals throughout the years, Bevan Spencer Von Einem is currently housed in the Port Augusta High Security Prison in the geriatric section.
当我问这个年轻男子是谁时，贝万说：“哦，只是个搭便车的人。”正如特雷弗·彼得斯所描述的那样，这组照片的画面感极强，因此其描述并未公开发布。据《广告人报》报道，20世纪90年代，特雷弗·彼得斯在日记中写道，他去卡尔vary医院的美发师那里，质问他关于十多年前在那家沙龙看到的照片。他们坐在医院的花园里，美发师告诉特雷弗，冯·艾内姆曾给他展示过许多照片。有几十个赤身裸体的年轻男子，通常还塞有包括瓶子在内的物体深入他们的肛门。特雷弗在日记中写道：“然而，他笑着对我说，他不记得沙龙里有过任何照片，如果你知道好歹，你最好也不要记得。”他四天后去世了。尽管多年来多次上诉，贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆目前被关押在奥古斯塔港高度安全监狱的老年区。
A sudden change in legislation was passed in 2007, months before Von Einem was eligible for parole, allowing the South Australian government to have non-parole periods revoked for prisoners classified as dangerous offenders. As such, Von Einem, now 74 years old, white-haired, and suffering from type 2 diabetes, will die in prison. In 2008, there was a change to DNA legislation in South Australia that gave police the power to test the DNA of people that were suspects in major indictable offences. A cold case review of the family murders was established, and in March 2008, detectives from the major crime and cold case units set about obtaining DNA samples from three major suspects and nine others associated with the crimes. The samples were compared to forensic evidence obtained in four of the five murder crime scenes, and the profiles stored on a database for future reference. Detectives were confident that as a result of the testing, other arrests would be made. In December 2010, it was revealed that the cold case review failed to uncover any new evidence, and no charges were laid. A reward of up to $200,000 is still on offer for information leading to the conviction of the person or persons responsible for the murders of Neil Muir and Mark Langley.
2007年，即冯·艾内姆有资格假释前几个月，通过了一项突如其来的立法变更，允许南澳大利亚州政府撤销对被归类为危险罪犯的囚犯的不得假释期。因此，现年74岁、白发苍苍且患有2型糖尿病的冯·艾内姆将在监狱中度过余生。2008年，南澳大利亚州的DNA立法发生了变化，赋予警察对重大可公诉罪行嫌疑人进行DNA检测的权力。家庭谋杀案的冷案复查启动，2008年3月，重案组和冷案组的侦探开始从三名主要嫌疑人和与这些罪行相关的另外九人那里获取DNA样本。这些样本与在五个谋杀犯罪现场中的四个现场获得的法医证据进行比对，并将档案存储在数据库中以备将来参考。侦探们确信，由于这次测试，将会进行其他逮捕。2010年12月，据透露，冷案复查未能发现任何新证据，也没有提出任何指控。对于提供线索导致对尼尔·缪尔和马克·兰格利谋杀案负责的一个或多个人定罪的信息，目前仍悬赏高达20万美元。
A reward of up to $1,000,000 is on offer for information leading to the conviction of the person or persons responsible for the murders of Alan Barnes and Peter Stognef. Despite Bevan Spencer von Einem having been found guilty of the murder of Richard Kelvin, police are convinced multiple perpetrators were involved in his death. Therefore, a $1,000,000 reward is also on offer for information leading to further convictions in his case. Detectives think that over the years, 100 or more young men were picked up, drugged, assaulted, and then let go by members of the family. If you have any information, please call Crime Stoppers on 1-800-333-000 or make a report online at crimestopperssa.com.au. You can remain anonymous. Or if you'd prefer, contact case file directly via our website. Speaking to the advertiser, Detective Superintendent Grant Moyle appealed to those with knowledge of the family murders. It is never too late for them to come forward and I don't think anyone involved in this should ever sleep easy.
对于提供线索导致对艾伦·巴恩斯和彼得·斯托涅夫谋杀案负责的一个或多个人定罪的信息，悬赏高达100万美元。尽管贝万·斯宾塞·冯·艾内姆已被判犯有谋杀理查德·凯尔文罪，但警方确信他的死有多名凶手参与。因此，对于提供线索导致在他的案件中取得更多定罪的信息，也悬赏100万美元。侦探们认为，多年来，有100名或更多的年轻男子被“家族”成员接走、下药、袭击然后放走。如果您有任何信息，请拨打止罪热线 1-800-333-000 或在 crimestopperssa.com.au 上在线举报。您可以保持匿名。或者如果您愿意，可以直接通过我们的网站联系案件档案。侦探总督察格兰特·莫尔在接受《广告人报》采访时呼吁那些了解家庭谋杀案的人。现在站出来永远不会晚，我不认为任何参与此事的人能安稳入睡。
No one should think these cases are forgotten. They are not. It is never too late for someone to come forward with information regarding them. We will follow it up. It was a sentiment echoed by Alan Barnes' brother Charlie, who said of those responsible, I would like them to shed the guilt and remorse they must be carrying around and come forward and bring this to a conclusion. I know the police are like bulldogs and will not let go of this. They may well tap you on the shoulder one day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
没有人应该认为这些案件已被遗忘。它们没有。任何人带着相关信息站出来永远都不算晚。我们会跟进的。艾伦·巴恩斯的兄弟查理也表达了同样的看法，他谈到负责人时说：“我希望他们能卸下他们一定背负的内疚和悔恨，站出来，给这件事画上句号。我知道警方就像斗牛犬一样，绝不会放过这一点。他们有一天可能会拍拍你的肩膀。”本集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。